Okay, and we're recording.
All right, it is 4:01 on September 15th,
and we will call this work session to order. I want to start
off by excusing Zach. He had some other obligations today. today,
Councilmember Huish. And just make sure— is Councilmember Wood
online? Okay, and Councilmember Wood is also online.
So glad you could join us. And, uh, we'll start right
off with the first item, 1A, discussion for transmission
lines. And, um, Brandon? Yeah,
thank you, Mayor. Um, I think I don't need to
belabor Kind of the background on this, we know there's,
we know about the transmission line project
that goes from Spanish Fork Canyon to the Mercer Substation. We,
you can see the preferred route, even zooming in a little
bit better, you can see it runs here in the yellow, and that takes
us right through our ag zone.
So we came to you a couple months ago
to get council's feedback and
see how you wanted us to handle— we've got this project, this transmission
line project, we've got data centers that need power, and so
we're like, how do we— how should we handle this
situation? We need transmission lines to go through
that area, even though transmission lines aren't allowed in the ag
zone. So the— we
were tasked, staff was, to prepare an overlay zone.
So we were going to start working on that
and then found out that Spanish Fork City had went
through a similar process of actually establishing an overlay zone
for the same purpose to give them control of
where that transmission line Would go through their city,
and then I talked. I spoke
with their community development director to find out kind of some background of
why they did the overlay zone, and then found out that
they repealed that overlay zone or abandoned it.
You know, several months later. So long
story short, what it came down to was there's a. There's state
requirements in the way that that really are
a little bit of a challenge to work with, and so that's from what
I gathered from Spanish Fork. My discussion with Spanish Fork City is they became
more aware of the state code requirements related to cities
and and the location permitting the
and and having a say in the the location
of transmission lines. And yes, there is an ability for
local municipalities to have— to be able
to permit these and place conditions on them.
But the— it looks like one of the big keys here is
providing safe, reliable, Excuse me, safe,
reliable, and adequate service to customers.
So,
like it says here in 54-14-201,
if otherwise authorized by law, local government may require
or condition the construction of a facility in any manner if the requirement
or condition doesn't impair the ability of the public utility to provide
safe, reliable, adequate service to its customers. So we
have the ability— what it really comes
down to is oftentimes cities end up having to pay the
actual excess cost. There's whatever—
if our requirements cost
the utility additional money, We have to pay for it oftentimes.
Now there are some ways that that doesn't
happen. There is a board, and I'll get to that in a second,
but oftentimes it appears that
we end up paying what the, again, the code, the state code calls
actual excess cost. There's a process that
cities can You can
go through this process with the utility and have them give you the estimate,
give you an estimate of how much it's gonna cost, and you can ask for
competitive bids. But ultimately,
it comes down to this. Once those actual
excess costs are known and there
isn't, like it says in A and B, the Utility
Commission or the Utility
Facility Review Board doesn't intervene in
some fashion to absolve the city from
having to pay, then we end up paying the excess costs.
So there's your definition of actual excess cost.
It can even include right-of-ways, you can see on the
screen there.
This chat, it's sub—
or Section 2 of 5414 talks,
kind of lays the groundwork for cities and
how they can interact in this process of requiring conditions
and so forth and permitting these transmission lines.
Last, the last bit of language there,
you can read that there. Any requirement or condition in any permit,
authorization, approval, or exception that
imposes an actual cost shall be considered waived. You basically have 30 days
to, if you're required to pay, you have to make
that payment within 30 days before
the construction of the facility to avoid— anyway,
if you don't pay it in a timely fashion, then your
right to actually have a say actually is waived.
So there is a board, like I said, the board
of The Utility Facility Review Board.
It is your 3 utility commissioners plus 2
other members. I think the utility company and then city
gets to choose somebody from a group of
people at the state government level to participate
in the process. And they'll
hear disputes between utilities and cities
basically about you know,
excess cost questions and so forth. So I
just want you to be aware of this as
we can prepare an overlay zone. We just want you
to be aware of Spanish Fork's, uh,
Spanish Fork situation, uh,
kind of their experience with it, and we wanted you to be aware of
the state code requirements. And so
with that, I'll let you— I'm here to answer any questions.
Mayor, is it okay if I ask a question? I'm just wondering,
does it make any sense to the council to continue to pursue an overlay
zone knowing that this is already highly regulated at the state level? I mean,
it's really, in my opinion, it's a question of Do we
want to impose some additional regulations and
are we willing to pay for them? That's what I'm hearing. That's my
interpretation of what we just read through. Is if we
feel strongly that we want the power
towers to be covered to look like pine trees and it costs $100,000
per pole extra, are we willing to pay that?
And I don't know, that's a really kind of a silly example,
but as I listened to this,
those were my thoughts. I don't know what the rest of you think.
So part of the reason for doing the overlay zone was so that we could
direct where those transmission lines would go,
right? And just
instead of, 'cause if we didn't wanna just put it willy-nilly and then
that anywhere, the ag it could go and then we lose
control of that. So that was part of the reason for the overlay. So is
it placing an additional condition on the utility if we're telling it where it needs
to go? Making sure
I'm still on there. If it impacts,
if it causes, if our condition ends
up costing the utility more money, yeah,
it becomes an impact to them and we have to pay pay more money.
So if they can buy a transmission corridor or an easement
for X number of dollars that runs right through
this piece of property, and we direct that it has to go through that piece
of property, and there's a cost differential between the two, we're going to have to
pay that. That's, that's exactly what I'm interpreting. And remember this,
they can— they're, they're a utility company, they can eminent domain anyway, even if you
told them no. They They can do what they want.
I— part of me is inclined to let the market help drive
where the transmission lines go, because they're
in the business of providing power for residents, and in the long run,
if we require something extra We end up paying
for it either way, whether it comes from taxpayer dollars or if
it comes through ratepayers. So I think we need to be really careful and
judicious about how much we are trying to
control where this goes. But I also know that when we first started
this conversation, there's several areas around
the city that are ag-zoned, and we don't want energy
utilities just running through wherever. So It
feels like a lot of this is predetermined by what the state requires
us to help fund if we're the ones that are instigating the cost.
So it's a little bit of— it's discouraging, I think, in a
lot of ways to even talk about it. But I don't
know. But this relates to just the public utility. So it's not private
transmission lines. So it's just the public utility. It's just public.
So maybe the way the council needs to go on this is we don't put
anything in code and we just wait and negotiate once an opportunity comes up.
And then we can negotiate whatever we want, including saying this is how
it's going to be and regard like and we can create in the code that
they waive their rights to whatever the state says. That's not the way
that I'm seeing it. I'm seeing that they basically. can come and secure their
own access and determine where they're going to put it and where
it's most cost-effective to do so. And that we really,
unless we choose to step into that process and pay
the cost of modifying anything that's outside of what
they're already willing to do, then it's kind of a moot point.
So if it's an allowed use, for instance, and it meets every
requirement in an allowed use of a zone, basically staff-level approval.
So it wouldn't— you would never have the chance to weigh in.
Right. Well,
go ahead. Let's see what Rich thinks. Rich, do you have a— Councilmember,
what are you— I'm here.
What I'm thinking of is— I can't hear you, Rich. I can see you talking,
though.
How about now? Can you hear me now?
It's not muted. No. We'll come back to you.
Um, did you have something else you wanted to say?
I was just going to mention that I feel like part of our issue too
is that we're surrounded by a lot of unincorporated
land or land that belongs in a different city. So,
however this gets to us, that will
always play a role in it. And maybe that's why the state has
played a bigger role in determining what can
happen in this space. So, it's just a factor that we always have
to be aware of. How about
now? Can you hear me now? Is the Merkur substation
the only one that is looking at upgrades? I mean, they've talked
about a transmission line that might come from the Twila Valley. Are there others
that we're aware of? None others.
I mean, to me it just doesn't seem like this is something that we want
to battle. I don't know how the rest of council feels.
If there was something meaningful that we wanted to do and we were
willing to pay for it, then certainly we could find a path forward there.
But from my perspective, I think if the public utility
company— I want to be clear— the public utility company determines that this is where
the line should be, this is the most cost-effective route, and this
is what they're going to do to put it in, why do we want to
stand in the way of that? I mean, we want them to bring the power
to our valley. That's the other consideration that we need to at least
recognize is if they choose not to bring power to our valley,
then that's going to limit our ability to But
at least we're vetting this. At least we're talking about it. At least we didn't
just have something happen without us trying to think in advance. So,
like, we're trying to still play from the front, but what we're realizing is we
don't have very— we don't hold the cards.
You hold the checkbook is what you hold. That's how I see
it. I mean, you have the checkbook that says if you're willing to pay for
it, you can certainly regulate it in any way that you'd like to, but you're
going to pay for it. pay for it, and you got to do it within
30 days of receiving notice, unless I misunderstood
something. That's how I understand it as well.
I mean, again, there is this Utility Facility Review
Board, um, if I keep forgetting the name of that, uh,
yes, Utility Facility Review Board, that, uh,
can, uh, we, we can take an issue, a dis— some
type of disagreement, and have them rule on it. So there is actually
a process And a possibility of
this board, and the commission as well,
they can take actions that may lead to the utility not
imposing some of the regulations, or some of the costs, I think
is a better thing to say, some of the costs that would typically come.
So there's kind of a built-in review and appeal process at the state
level already. But there's not much— I mean,
we can't rely on that. Right, exactly. They're not— it's not a good
backstop. So we're still not required to put
transmission lines as an approved use in ag. We just wait
basically for the utility company to come and tell us where they're going to go.
Yeah, I— well,
again, yeah, I guess if we say otherwise,
it's just going to cost the city money, it looks like. It seems like we
can still open a dialogue with them though and say, hey, here's some preferred routes
we would really like you to go if possible. Yeah, and we have
that ability. Commissioner— or excuse me, Councilor Wright
has been in our DRC meetings, and they have
Rocky Mountain Power and their consultants have come in
the last few months to our DRC meeting to talk about the
transmission line and getting permits and so forth.
So we can continue to ask
for them to adjust their application
in a way that'd be favorable to the city. And we,
of course, have a council member on there who's
well aware of what happens on the DRC. All right. For now,
while they're working on this other issue, I'm going to let Councilmember Wood weigh in
on the phone. Can you hear us okay, Councilmember Wood?
Yeah, can you hear me? Yeah, go ahead.
So, the couple questions that I have, first of all, is this not covered under
our overlay zone for the energy production overlay zone? And why
not just add it to the zone that we've already created? That's my first question.
The second question is, I think that we do at least want to have some
input as to the— how the
line comes into the city. I mean, obviously, it's got to follow a certain connection
route. Um, but we— I think we want to have some input
in what that looks like. They do that.
Yeah, um, we want to— towers or things
like that, I'm less concerned about things like that, just more or less
the impact of the line itself.
The alternative energy overlay zone, um,
it We can certainly,
we can require them to
go through the rezone process.
I don't have the code right in front of me. I don't recall that we
have specific requirements for transmission lines in there.
But I know that we also have in our
1770, Chapter 1775
of the city code, there are relatively few
requirements already in there related to transmission lines.
So I just don't know how much traction or how much it will help to
put that land in the alternative energy overlay
zone as it relates to the location of transmission
lines. And your other question, I'm trying
to— Can I ask a follow-up question to that, Brandon? Yeah.
Okay, go ahead. So the transmission lines
that we're talking about, are we talking about them coming from Spanish Fork
or from the actual natural gas facility?
From Spanish Fork. They'll, they'll come Can
you see the screen, Rich? Is that— No, they rebooted my computer. I think they're
trying to figure out how to get me connected, so I can't see anything right
now. They basically start in Spanish Fork Canyon, wrap around the bottom
of Utah Lake, and then cut through the
backside of like the Lake Mountains and then
into Cedar Valley. And is this the direct
connection to the, to the current line then? Yeah,
well, to the Mercer substation. Mercer substation.
Okay. I don't
really have any issue with the creation of a code, frankly, but I
think we can probably accomplish that with the overlay that
we have. I mean, I think for me at least, that was the intent of
that overlay zone for all energy production, including transmission lines.
I think Councilmember Wood, I mean, here's— I'm listening to what you're saying
and trying to kind of process it. I think that
the difference that I'm seeing is that this is regulated as
a public utility by the state. And I think what
you're referencing are those alternative
overlay energy projects that we perhaps may entitle
in the city of Eagle Mountain that are behind the meter generation
facilities. And I think that's the substantive difference
in in perhaps the 2 things that we're talking about.
What are your thoughts about that? I'm not saying that.
What I'm saying is it's coming through the same area.
My understanding is they do have to at least follow existing zoning,
correct? No,
that's where they— I think they have the power of eminent domain, so they
don't have to.
So that's where we're at. What is the point of doing an overlay zone if
they don't have to follow any of the zoning anyway? Well, and that's the
crux of the debate. I think
the question's answered then. That's exactly what they've been saying.
There's no reason to do this if there's nothing we can do, right?
I mean, that's— those are— I mean, I think we are
coming to a consensus. That's what I'm hearing, is that
if there's nothing we can do to regulate it, then why are we trying to
create Create a zone that we can't regulate anyway. And if we do regulate it,
it's just going to cost us money. Yeah, only pertaining to public utilities.
Yes. Yeah. So, so maybe what
I'm hearing is that this overlay zone would work on a behind-the-meter,
but in that case, what's the impact?
Do you want to do something for outside of public?
Well, I, I think our alternative energy overlay zone already contemplated
that, if I remember right. We'd have to go back and look at the language.
I think Marcus is— it talks about transmission lines in that, in that overlay.
And frankly, they're through the development agreements.
That's where we've given the entitlements to produce those energy,
the behind-the-meter energy production anyway. And so
I think that the city still has several levers that they can pull to
help design that in such a way that they're comfortable with the outcome.
So are we certain that they don't want to work with us on this in
the first place?
They, they have been cooperative. They— I think they're—
we— they came in to the DR to,
to get information about submitting applications.
Well, around the 1st of June, if I recall correctly, maybe May.
And we told them, so when we
go through that process, we just kind of give them a bunch of background information,
requirements they need to go through, and then kind of tell them about constraints
they may run into. And so obviously, this ag zone,
the ag zone not allowing transmission lines,
that was the biggest roadblock. And so they,
They actually were the ones that they've gently
just kind of pointed to the fact to the state code. They're like, "You also
might want to talk to Spanish Fork." And yet they didn't really give me
a lot of feedback initially, but they're like, "You might want to go talk
to Spanish Fork because they've been down this path and hear from them what kind
of their their experience with trying to create an overlay." So I
did, and I'm reporting back what I heard, what I
found out in my own code research.
So— So we good to move on on this one, or is there
further direction for staff?
No, I think— Doesn't sound like there's anything we can do. Exactly my
thought. I think we just say thanks for looking into it and bringing us this
information. And that helps us make a decision that it's
better off not to make a decision about this.
Okay, let's roll on. I'm going to keep you on the phone
for a second, Rich, until I find out if this is there, but I'm going
to put it on mute. So if you need
something, raise your hand or something, we'll get to you.
Discussion item 1B, I think we're going to hold off on that one. I've mentioned
before the meeting, Councilmember Wood, I didn't get a chance to tell you, but that
was one that Council Member Hewish wanted to weigh in on, and I think
we're better served to hold off on that one to maybe the next
meeting. So if Lacey, if you don't mind putting that on a future agenda.
It is somewhat urgent, but I don't think it's super urgent, so we'll skip
by that one. And then discussion once— item 1C,
the discussion about the project recommendations from
the community board. Steve, did you have an introduction, or is this Turn it
over to the board. Oh, we can turn it over to Jesse, who's representing the
board, and Charlotte's here as well. So.
Give us just one second. I think we're
recording. Oh, we're good.
Just not what? No sound? I thought you were asking about Rich,
but Rich is not back. Yeah, we're good. I'll keep him on the phone for
a minute and tell— if something changes, we'll figure
it out. Okay.
Good afternoon, Mayor and Council. I really appreciate
the opportunity to come and present this to you today. And before I get
started, I want to recognize the strain that both our staff and our budget are
under right now. And the last thing I want to do is add
unnecessarily to either of those, which is why we took careful
consideration in crafting this list. I also want to express
my gratitude for all of the help staff has already given us on the Community
Services Board. And for all of the work that each of you continues to put
into our city, the information that we put
together here came from a few different places. We gathered it from discussing
with residents at different events in the city.
There was an app that was created that had customer or customer
resident feedback, and then a lot of this was just things that members of the
board had seen around the city. We then
dedicated the majority of one of our board meetings to discussing what we believed should
be priorities for the city, and we specifically
tried to identify things that could be meaningful wins without necessarily taking on
another massive project. And then we— from
there, I did some additional research to
better understand what could actually be feasible and what we could realistically ask.
Thank you. This is the
list that we came up with. I do want to point out that as a
board, we did not rank these recommendations beyond agreeing that they
belonged on this list. But I intentionally left
them this way because I know that funding is tight right now and
that it may not be feasible to address all of these immediately.
However, as I researched each one further, I found some pretty compelling reasons why every
one of them deserves consideration. Thank you. Consideration as a priority.
The first one is ADA curb ramp installations.
There are currently these, at least these 5 locations
that were pointed out to me by a resident where the
trail does not have an ADA ramp.
In the staff report, Steve noted that the average cost is approximately $4,450
per ramp. And that's not an insignificant amount of money.
And I don't know exactly how many there will be, but I do think that
they're important improvements for us to make. One of
our board members made a comment during our discussion that I think summed this all
up, and it's that our city should be accessible for everyone.
Did you have something? Yeah, go ahead. Yeah, I do have a question.
And it's, so at 44, 50 per ramp at each of these
locations that the board has identified. Are— does that mean there's 4
ramps at this intersection, or is it just one? There's 5. These are
5 different locations. 5 locations. But let's take Shep's Ridge and
Overland Pump Track. Is it just one ADA ramp, or is it multiple ADA
ramps at that location? So there would just be one at that one, and then
on the other side is a different— so it would be the White Rock Road
would be the other side of the trail. Each of these 5 represent one ramp
apiece? Yes. Okay, I think so. Just real quick, I wanted to either get
Zach or Brad to weigh in. A couple of these we had identified earlier on
and might already be on some lists. Is that which is very possible?
True. I know there was one in down
here to the south. What's that called? Talking about Sweetwater.
Sweetwater. Is this and some of them the sidewalk was meant to go
100 feet to the East or west, and then there was one. So— Well,
Mayor, I think that there's already a funding source identified for
these ADA ramps from the CDBG funds. And that's why I was asking. I mean,
didn't we talk about that? Yeah, I think that we've had
communication that that funding could be utilized for something of this nature.
Well, I— yeah, so I think this one's a no-brainer.
Me personally.
Awesome. Can I just make one point before we move on with that though?
On some of these, we need to look at them because when we build ADAs,
we gotta be careful. Like, is the trail continuing through
and does that create a crosswalk scenario?
Is the ADA intended to be there or is there an ADA at
the corner, at the intersection,
and this is a cross-section road?
Definitely willing to look at the list and you know assess it, but there's
a few other variables I think we need to look at through that process.
That's why I was wondering if there's additional feedback because I know we looked at
one down here that has that exact question.
So we can look further into those. All right,
good. Can I ask just a quick question too, Mayor? Since we only have
this one item, have we fixed the
loophole? In our requirements for neighborhoods so
that this stuff doesn't happen anymore? How did we get
to the point where one of these trails didn't have an ADA
ramp?
I think that's something that we're going to have to assess on a case-by-case.
I think as we develop our subdivisions and the
communities, we look at those plans and we try to make sure that those cross-sections
are there and the ADA ramps. exist. Um, some of these areas,
uh, I'm, I'm not familiar with these intersections, so I haven't seen
them, so I'll have to go out and look at them and assess them.
But, uh, it's, it's definitely something that we try
to collect in our DRC, our plan reviews, and try to make sure that everything's
compliant and in line. I, I totally get that,
and I know that you guys make great efforts to make sure all of
those things happen, but I'm wondering if we need to have something in our
code or in our process that would
make sure that these ADA curb ramps are
there, just like we require that there's X amount of streetlights
and X amount of park amenities and things like that. So I'm just wondering if
this is something we ask the planning department
to take a look at code-wise to help—
Make it always work out the right way?
I mean, we can definitely look at anything and put it in code, but I
think what is gonna really dictate this on how these exist
and whatnot will be these future master plans with our trails and
whatnot. They should outline and show that connectivity.
And, you know, when it comes to ADA and sidewalk,
there's other plans in place, and there's
some other plans I think us as a community that we're going to probably have
to get involved in because, you know, ADA is one of the biggest compliance
things that we have to follow. And we're trying to get on a maintenance schedule.
We're trying to add these additional ADA ramps and those things as
they come up. So the best case scenario I can give you for today
with this is we can assess each of these locations and see if it
warrants it. And if And if we— if it needs one, or we'll
do what we need to to get it installed. Thanks.
Can I add just one other thing too? So if you're saying, Brad, that there
might be a ramp down, like, down a ways,
if the rest of the family's going this way, but they've got an ADA and
they said, well, now we're gonna have to detour to bring you in, I'm still
open to adding more ramps to make it better for those that are
traversing. And I hear you. If it's a through cross— if it's
a trail segment that's crossing a roadway, then we need to assess it in that
situation. But that's not true in every scenario. Sometimes trails
go to a sidewalk and they tee. And that's what I'm saying is we wouldn't
want to put an ADA into the roadway on a tee.
That's why it needs to be assessed. This might have an ADA
ramp a couple hundred feet to the east at a stop sign. And this is
mid-block where you're— now you've got a crosswalk situation or something.
So we need to look at those. And then I was just
going to— I think I know the answer to this. I don't remember that $4,450
was a number that you got from engineering, or is
that? From streets.
Okay, Steve got it from— I just—
and we're pretty confident in that number, right? Yeah, that's reasonable.
Okay, just so that we know the fiscal impact. Go ahead.
Thank you. Our next item is trail signage.
The off-street trails master plan that was recently passed
identified 39 signage-related issues throughout
our trail system. And some of them are a little
more than just an inconvenience. There are blind intersections where
ATVs and mountain bikes can meet without adequate visibility or warning.
Trail difficulty isn't always marked, which means a beginner can unintentionally end up
on a much more advanced trail. Boundaries aren't always clear, making it easy for someone
to leave designated trail without realizing it.
And in many areas, the permitted uses aren't
obvious, so users don't know whether it's a trail for bikes,
ATVs, horses, or anything else.
Our recommendation is
to create cohesive signs that address
all of those issues that would improve safety and make trails easier
to navigate. and create a better experience for everyone using them.
I love this one because I think one of the things that we hear a
lot from residents is either enforcing something
that should or shouldn't be on a trail,
noise from certain things that shouldn't be adjacent to
backyards at 3 in the morning, just different things like that. And I think
having good signage defining what is there,
Both for the
ability and the difficulty of a trail, but also just to help
people understand what's allowed there and not is the first step into
being able to enforce something down the road too.
So I hope we can fund this.
Is that 39, meaning there's 39 identified locations? Yeah.
Okay. Just as we go on, and I actually wrote down
I like this one too. Melissa said that. I just don't
want it to fall on deaf ears. So as we get going, great presentation.
I just want to make assignments. So keep that in mind that— It said
39 issues. It could be that there are locations, but I would assume that's
what that means. Mayor? Can I just
ask— Can you guys hear me yet? So is that 39 pertaining to
the app? Is that how that is correlated?
'Cause then you collect this information— No, this is from the off-street
trails master plan. This is from— okay. So there's no correlation back
to the app. I just was wondering if that's what the 39 was.
No. The next one we have on
here is benches at Smith Ranch Park. Smith Ranch
Park is an awesome park, and it has 3 different playgrounds and
multiple fields and cool wildlife area, and it's It's— there's a
lot for families to do there. However, around those playgrounds,
there's nowhere to sit. And as a
mom who has taken her kids there to play, it would be really nice if
there were benches or something to sit
on so that I wouldn't have to bring a camp chair to watch them.
It was noted in the staff report that it would be just under $1,000 per
bench. We also had the thought that if
it were allowed, small businesses, or not
necessarily small businesses, but businesses in the community could donate a bench.
Because I know they're always looking for opportunities to give back to the community,
and I think that would be beneficial. I don't know how many benches we would
need, but at least a few around each playground would
be awesome. I also really like this idea. One thing
that I've heard over the years of serving from different neighborhoods
is when someone from a neighborhood passes away, like a
small child or something like that, almost always
I have residents reach out and say, we want to do something,
we'd like to donate this memorial or donate something.
And I think this allows us to
achieve 2 things. One, provide more seating, but then
also a standardized option for creating
a memorial bench in a loved one's honor. And I think
we could do it as a pilot program at Smith Ranch Park,
and as we see how that works,
we could potentially expand it to other parts of the city so
that people can designate where they'd like for a memorial bench to be placed.
And I like that the park staff is picking out the
quality and type of bench so it's not just some kid's Eagle
project, but it's actually something that will stay and
last in a city park.
So. The next one would be the maintenance
of the rodeo grounds. This is something that I've heard from several members of the
community who own and ride horses. And particularly one member of our board who
this has been an issue for. Currently, the grounds are groomed and prepared
like a week before the rodeo each year, within that week.
And then within about a week after the rodeo,
I've been told that the arena surface becomes difficult or unusable again,
and it generally stays that way until preparations begin for the next
rodeo. And when we're talking about maintenance, we are specifically
talking about maintaining the dirt surface pictured in this to
the left, not maintaining the entire facility.
Um, however, during my research, I did find that the current
lease agreement with Pony Express Events could create some confusion about
who's responsible for certain types of maintenance, and so that may need
to be reviewed. Um, but ultimately,
our recommendation as a board is that the city take on the responsibility
for maintaining the dirt and add it to some maintenance schedule
like with the rest of the parks in the city.
Our next one is more of a fun
one. We are recommending wildlife-themed utility
box art. This was brought to us by
a member of the board who is also part of the Wildlife Alliance.
And the idea is to take some of the utility boxes through the city
and wrap them in artwork similar to these examples.
The estimated cost is about $1,000 to $1,500 per box,
and we would need to coordinate with Rocky Mountain Power to determine which boxes could
be approved. And there are,
as far as I understand, funds set aside from capital projects that are restricted
to be used for public art, and we
thought that this would be a really creative use of those
funds. We also thought that it would be great to provide
some community engagement for— and we could have like an art contest and
decide which pieces of art could be displayed on these.
And the art itself should last 5
to 7 years if we wrap it in vinyl.
The next one is Nolan Park. I think we all
know that Noland Park has a lot of potential, but right now we're not getting
everything out of it that we could.
The fields are used, but the baseball diamonds aren't configured
to accommodate full baseball games. The splash pad's unusable,
and there is nowhere to park. Our recommendation is
that the city begin the process of a redesign of the park sooner rather
than later. It's intentionally lower down on the priority
list because the IAE recognized that redesigning and eventually rebuilding a park is much larger
and more expensive undertaking than several of
the other recommendations.
But it would be
useful to at least start the process, gain resident
feedback, and see what it is that we want to build and
where— what direction we should go, if we have to do a new splash pad
or not. I know that that's important to a lot of residents. I heard that.
just to gain resident feedback and see what the next steps would need to
be and if we need to hire a firm. But we, we believe that that's
something worth considering at this time.
Really quick, um, I think that
this is important because it's something that's been talked about for several years,
and I think we just need to rip the Band-Aid off and start
working forward with a plan. If we can't pay for something
for a while and we need to phase it in smaller chunks, that's okay too.
The one thing that I want us to make sure we consider
is Nolan Park East, which is kind of like
a section not in the main square of
Nolan Park, but is to the east of it. It's got a pavilion
and quite a bit of grass space. South of the church there?
It would be north of the church.
Along there. It's along, what is that road over
there, Peregrine? Yes. So it's right along Peregrine
and it faces the townhomes right there. There are,
when I've been there at Nolan Park East, I've seen a lot of people take
their dogs from the higher density housing and
go over there and let their dogs run and play in that area.
We've talked about community gardens that might be a place that's
near density.
And I think that since we have kind of a community garden pilot
program we're starting up, this would be a great second location to consider.
But for sure, it's important to me that we're looking at Nolan Park
holistically and not just the square, but also Nolan Park East.
Thank you.
The last one is a— it's about a championship-level
disc golf course. And I want to emphasize what we're actually
asking is not for the city to select a
location or design a course or spend money constructing one.
Our recommendation is to engage with Firefly and explore
whether this is something that could make sense within their community.
Pictured on the left is our current disc
golf course, and it works for casual play, but it really isn't suitable for more
serious or avid players. The space is confined enough that
longer throws can end up near or in people's backyards,
which is not ideal. Firefly has expressed some interest in potentially
having a championship-level course there, and they have consistently looked
for opportunities to bring unique amenities into their community.
So our ask is just that the conversation is had with Firefly on if this
is something that could— that they could be interested in,
and then if they are, that you guys seriously consider allowing
and supporting that opportunity. But of course, they have
not committed to anything. So that
is all. Thank you. I really appreciate you taking the time to hear these
today, and if you have any questions. Yeah, let's— I know we're
going to back up a little ways. Uh, I've got Council Member Wood on the
line again, and we'll go to him for some questions. Did you want to go
back to— Yeah, yeah, I just have a couple things just
to address. So with the signage, I think you're right on those,
but I think we need to codify this so that everything going forward has those
safety standards in place. And then we need to put it on a schedule to
go address that while we're efficient on all of our Trails.
Trails. And again, I don't think we have the money to do everything all at
the moment, but if we don't put a plan in place that addresses how we're
going to pay for these things and get them in, uh, into a routine of
getting updated and fixed, it's never going to happen.
We'll be talking about it again in a year. The second thing, uh,
I agree with the assumptions made about Miller Park, but I maybe
would like to see a little different approach. I think that we have other parks
that have problems as well, and we need to have— this would
be something that would be a real benefit from our Community Services Board to
evaluate what is the most meaningful first for
each of the parks, to put that in a priority list, and then let's
put a plan together to start addressing them. Because I think it's
more than just Miller Park. I mean, we're aware of what the splash pad issue
is. But I think that there are other parks that require the same type of,
uh, to be addressed. And if we don't put it on a plan
to address them, then it never gets funded.
Rich, she did mention park benches at,
uh, Smith Ranch was another one, and then Nolan Park.
And those were the 2 main parks, but definitely had those too.
I don't have an issue with putting the benches in. I think that's a
good amenity. I mean, people can use them When their kids are playing,
people who are walking and want to take a break, or runners,
or people that just want to sit at the park. I think that's an amenity
that should be in all of our parks. I just want to
agree with Council Member Wood. I think that we've talked about making
some upgrades to even at the Silver Lake Park where the amphitheater
is and the playground and the walking trail around there. This might
be a time to imagine what else could go there.
We've talked about landslides that
are on the side of the hill there and just different things, and maybe
beefing up and adding bathrooms down by the amphitheater
part so that the summer camp that takes place there every
summer has an actual place for them to change in and out of costumes and
just different things like that. So I like the idea of
asking our Community Services Board to look at all of the parks
and help prioritize some of the most urgent needs.
I'm okay with that, but I'd want them to have maybe an email or
something to say, hey, look here, and this is an idea, because otherwise it's just
kind of throwing darts. So if it's things like the slide that I know we've
talked about, I just, I want to
make sure we're giving them good direction. Mayor, I think that we
need to make sure that we're doing this in conjunction with our new parks manager.
I'm assuming the global plan that they're going to be providing,
and I think that they should be working with the Community Services Board, but I'd
like to see a maintenance plan to bring the parks to a level that
I think we're all comfortable with, which is going to require assessing each of the
parks and where they're currently at with their landscaping,
the equipment that's there, the trails, etc.
I think adding what Melissa said on top of that, finishing some of the parks
needs to be part of that. But if those aren't all prioritized in,
you know, going to this park, here are the things that needs to happen.
We go to this park, here's the things that need to happen. We need to
put those into some sort of a budget plan or it will never happen.
Yeah, and just probably a good time to tell you a meeting that I had
earlier this week and, uh, with our parks manager Kyle. I told
him that I think he should start coming to council meetings,
especially when these things are on the Agenda. And then not
only that, also direction to start sitting
in with Steve. Steve's got a heavy lift right now, and we
invited him to start sitting in on these— the monthly meetings, because I
think that for now that most of what we're talking
about affects him anyway, right? And Steve and I talked about
that. And I did speak with Kyle, and he was not available to come
tonight to this presentation. But he is planning on coming
to our board meetings whenever they're available. Yes, sir. Definitely on the same page there.
I think we saw that same hole, and I think that's important.
Was there other comments on some of those,
or anything you wanna see kind of pushed up the list?
With that now out there, we already know
there's some funding sources for some things.
I would like to say, sorry, were you gonna hop in? No, go ahead.
I would like to say that I really do support us having more regular rodeo
ground maintenance. I know there's been kind of an evolution of what the city
takes ownership of and what the nonprofits take ownership
of and different things like that. But for it to be consistent
and cared for with the proper equipment and all of those things,
I would like for us to find out what that fiscal
impact's gonna be on us to take that on, and whether we can work that
into the schedule. And even if it's once a month to start instead
of once a year, that at least is pushing us more in the right direction.
Because it's a huge asset. If we support the
Western way of life out here and our Western roots,
then I think we should take care of one of the, you know, The biggest
amenities that we have that reflects that. So I really support that.
I'm glad that it's on the list. Yeah,
I just thought, well done. I'm grateful for the presentation,
Jesse. I would just say that I'm supportive of looking at all of what
you've brought forward. I think the ADA ramps is a
pretty straightforward thing, assuming that our staff finds that
they'll be compliant. They're in the right location,
and I like that there's already a ready-made funding source to take care of
that that comes from outside of the city. Okay,
those those CBDG funds I think can be used for
that. The trail signage certainly okay with that.
We it's just a matter of where do we find the resources to tackle that.
The Smith Ranch benches I love what you said, Councilmember Clark. I think.
I think offering those as a memorial bench and having folks
purchase or donate them makes a lot of sense to me.
And if not, then we can look at something else. Rodeo maintenance, I don't disagree
with that. I guess the question that I have and the suggestion I would make
is if we're going to put more resources into maintaining that, then should
we be looking for an opportunity to rent that space out?
Reserve that space to do something that's outside of perhaps,
and maybe that's a good or maybe that's a bad idea, but I just want
to open up that at least that line of thought.
The wildlife— can I jump in on that for just a second? Just so I
remember this year, it would have been our budget discussion
a year ago. We bought a new tractor and I said keep that old tractor
and let's use it over there. I don't know how I'd have to get some
feedback from staff about how much the old ones used compared to the new one,
but we only ever had one. Now we have two. And the thought was that
it could sit over there, just like mowing the grass at the
soccer field. We don't necessarily rent that out. It would get too much abuse
possibly without the, you know, things in this type
of an industry get damaged. But I think
open riding for our residents and having mowed grass type
of— I'm open to all that, Mayor, and I'm not disagreeing with you in any
way. You're the horseman. And I'll certainly respect that.
For me, it's just a matter of can we find it, can we find
a way to make that more useful? And I think that's probably the goal.
Yeah, and I wanna just, so for context, I guess what I'm saying is just
like putting gas in a lawnmower and mowing the grass once a week, we're gonna
put gas in a tractor that we already own and take 15 minutes to plow
the dirt. That's the extent. And if that's all it takes, then let's, I mean—
I think that's what they're asking. Yeah. Can I, let me finish.
Go ahead. Maybe one step further on that. Uh, I think that—
aren't we also supposed to be using the tractor over in the Memorial Park as
well for, uh, the cemetery?
Isn't that why we kept the old one? I think is the question.
And I don't know how much use is over there or not.
I, I don't know off the top of my head. I can't, I can't answer
and say that it's this many hours, but yeah, there's several different pieces that equipment
that gets transported around and used for several different items. If we
don't have— Both tractors are in use, I guess, would be— Yeah, we use both
of them. Just at this point, our city's getting big enough we could have a
third one, right, Brad? Well, it's just time and money,
right? I mean, I've, I've taken time and I've, I've groomed the rodeo grounds.
I, I— you say 15 minutes, but I think it's longer than 15 minutes to
turn that arena. I think it's a couple-hour deal. And if you're going to do
it 3 times a week, those, those numbers add up. And so
I think we just got to look within our budgets and see what we can
facilitate. And if it's a service level thing and we want to
bolster it up and we want to provide the services and more
time and money and staff, then, then we can, we can do these things for
sure. Yeah, go ahead and finish, Brett. All right. And then probably just the
last one that I'll comment on, and everything else that's been said I agree with,
but the wildlife Utility boxes. I like that idea. And I,
again, there's, I think, a ready-made funding source that's available for that.
And I think that you tried to identify that. So you, I thought I was
waiting for you to weigh in on this. 0.25%. Yeah, the quarter. The quarter percent
that we're collecting for capital projects. On capital projects. On capital projects that's being set
aside into a special fund for art. I think it would be nice
to start to put some of those funds to work. And I personally think
this is a good place to start. Are there
other things we should consider? Certainly, but this would start to give some return
on those collections that we've been taking. Just for context,
I think there's— we were trying to figure that out today. We got a phone
call and Ben and I were at the Capitol. There's about $49,000?
$48,000, I believe. $48,000? At one time.
$47,000 in that account just on capital Probably just a quarter of 1%.
Yeah, and I don't think we need to spend it all here, but I think
that you could certainly identify, you know, a half dozen or 10 of the most
impactful locations and then work through,
'cause we have to develop the process as to how you're gonna pick artists and
who's gonna decide what goes on there. And that's
a whole nother can of worms that we gotta work through. All right,
I wanna go back to Councilmember Wood real quick.
Was there more on that one? I just want to jump back to the rodeo
grounds. I think that we need to make a decision of whether or not it's
a park or not. If we're going to treat it like it's a— it's
always going to be in disrepair. If we're going to treat it like it's a
park, then we need to make it available to people. People need
to be aware that it's there for their use and we need to maintain it
as such. But I think we can't continue to pretend like it's
not something that we need to maintain. Because we're really touching it once a
year. So if we're going to make it available
to everybody, then what is the use that we're going to make it available for?
Are we allowing it to be a riding arena? If so, that tells you exactly
what type of surface we need to put in there as far as the dirt
goes. If we're going to let people come in and do other types of things
that's going to commingle the dirt, then we'll have to scrape it before the rodeo
every year.
Um, I had a similar thought to Council Member
Wright about, well, maybe we should be charging for it and different things.
But then as I was sitting here thinking about it, we don't really charge anyone
to come and use our pickleball courts or our tennis courts or
anything like that. It's an amenity that we put in. Um,
if someone's going to— Maybe just schedule it.
Yeah, schedule it. Or if someone's going to make money from it, like if they're
going to host a A big event that's— 4-H. Yeah, 4-H something
or other, or something that's not necessarily city-driven.
I, I think maybe then we could look at some
sort of fee schedule or something. But in general, I think
that it's our duty as a council to figure out how to fund
the maintenance and care of that space. And then,
um, as we go through people using it, if there's
inappropriate uses or something like that, let's cross
that bridge when we come to it. Yeah, I just— my understanding is
that it is in use already. It is open to the public year-round.
People come in, they bring their dogs, use it as a dog park during
the off-season, and people go in and Do other sort of recreational
activities there. It's just a question of, you know, we have an agreement
that puts the burden of maintenance on a particular group and it's
not working out and how should we move forward?
I think that's the suggestion that they're making is that perhaps the city should look
at that and say, is there a different approach we can take to for the
maintenance of it so that it becomes an even more utilized
facility than what it is currently? I mean, it's certainly
being utilized, and I'm aware of that, Marcus.
But I think that at least what I'm hearing is how could we make it
a little more useful for more people? That's what I'm hearing.
Yeah, I would agree with that. I mean, I think that we've listed it
as one of our parks. That's supposed to be what the use of it is,
so we should be maintaining it as such. And to Melissa's point, I don't think
that we should be charging people unless they're trying to reserve it like a pavilion.
If they want the full use of the facility, then they go through the same
planning or the event— what is that—
reservation that everybody else does for pavilions or a portion of the park.
And we have a fee schedule that's set up for that. Otherwise, it's available for
people to use, and there probably ought to be some At least some restrictions
about what could be done on the dirt. So I think
what I've seen in other cities, I'm just floating this out there for you guys
to consider. For instance, it's just open riding, and the
key here is that the ground's in a condition that it can be rode,
you know, rode in. Compare it to a pavilion. The pavilion's there, there's tables
there, you can sit down, you can eat lunch, you can come and go as
you please. It's open to everybody. If you want to rent
the pavilion or block it off to where others can't use it because you have
a birthday party, You call the city and you reserve the pavilion for
$30 an hour or whatever that is, and then you have your event and then
you go on. And that's, that's exactly how Spanish Fork
and other arenas do that. That's what I'm talking about. So, so there's— if you're
the 4-H and you want to block off from 7 to 9 on a Monday
night, you call in and you pay your $30 an
hour fee type of deal, and— or $50 or whatever, that would
be in the fee schedule. But it's open riding unless you're bringing in an
approved use. I agree with that, but I also think that
we should have an application for a fee waiver for specific
things that are serving our community. For example, the FFA
kids at our local high school may need it for something specific,
and they may need it to be blocked off specifically for them,
but they're not a for-profit entity. Mutton busting. Yeah,
mutton busting. They are kids that are growing up here in this community And
I think that there should be a mechanism by which organizations
and people can request that that fee is not assessed
or waived. So that's just something that I also
think that the Community Services Board could help tackle. Okay.
I was just gonna say, 'cause I haven't chimed in, I'm very supportive of what
the Community Services Board's been doing. Super grateful for what your work is, and I'm
really good with your recommendations. And my one question, Can RAP tax dollars
go towards some of this? Certainly. Any of it.
Absolutely. And since we have RAP tax dollars, it seems
to me that this plan can be implemented. So I think we go forward.
I think my understanding is that RAP tax dollars
could go to any of this, yet there's other— Except for operation. Well, there's also
additional restricted funds that we use as well. So for instance, the ADA would
be RAP tax and/or the CBDG. The trail signage would
probably be RAP tax. The maintenance of the rodeo grounds could not be RAP tax
is my guess. That's it. Right. That could still be RAP tax.
You can use it to fund operations. Oh, okay, there you go. Yeah, you actually
could. My question with that would be we're currently developing
a process by which people apply for RAP tax funding. Is this something
that would need to go through that process for things like this? I don't
think that it should. I've seen that other cities, Lehi specifically,
There's a chunk of that money that the city designates
to go toward projects that they've heard from the community
broadly need to be done and taken care of in their parks.
And then there's a chunk of their rat tax that the community
service or rat board goes through and makes determinations and awards
grants and different things like that. I think that there will be certain
things that we as a body who has that responsibility
over all budget and all funds to say, yep,
this chunk is gonna go to take care of some of those needs that have
been identified by the Community Services
Board and identified by listening to residents and still
meet that objective of letting the people on the Community Services Board be
able to weigh in on how those funds are used.
I think that's kind of, that's one of the things that I've said for a
long time is, I like that they've come with the initiative of these are
some kind of low-hanging fruit, as I would call it, that we can do.
Like the Smith Ranch benches can be funded
with sponsorship money, but that it's— we
can do this with all kinds of different funds, and that's up
to us to allocate funds on whatever that looks like, right?
So some of it could be RAP tax, of course, but some of it could
be all kinds of different How long do you want to wait for donations to
come in on Smith Ranch Park before you decide we just got to do it
ourselves? Like, I don't want this to hang out forever saying we're waiting. So I
think you put a deadline out there, you say we want sponsors,
and if the sponsors don't come in by a certain deadline, we build it ourselves
and not wait. What method are you going
to use to solicit them? I think that needs to be decided, right?
Like sponsorships? That would be
decided. Remains to be seen. Can the city
help with advertising for that, for the sponsorships? Are you talking about
for benches? Sorry, Councilmember Wright.
I think it could be just as simple as the process that
they put in place for the banners on the sides of the pickleball courts.
But it also could be something that's listed where
we have our cemetery plots. Like, if they're memorial benches,
we could put them there as an option for people to purchase
as a part of that. And then they also could be listed where we have
sponsorship opportunities for rec-type stuff.
We already have— And if you slid a piece of paper into their utility bill
also. Sure. We already have an amenity,
like, replacement repair line item. And it's
something that we could add some additional benches to out of— that's in our— that's
already budgeted for. And so I, I don't think we have to
go to the level that like we want benches there and we have to go
to a memorial program. I'm not saying that you, you can't. You guys
could develop a memorial program and that's something that we could implement. But I think
we could get some benches in sooner with some of those funds.
The other thought that I have is I think it's going to be good to
go out and obviously assess the parks and whatnot.
We do have our asset management program that
we've been trying to get all of our data into, and that's playgrounds, benches,
everything. And one thing that we gotta be aware of is sometimes,
you know, we're gonna make large purchase scale items like
playgrounds and whatnot, but we have to be protective that we wanna try
to use those out for their useful life. And that's part of what this asset
management program's And so as we see things in disrepair or
whatnot, we definitely want to know about those things. But then we have to weigh
it against the overall condition of it and a replacement schedule of it
as well. And so there will be some balance as we work through that.
We're willing and we're trying to develop that, and it's
getting a little bit better each day. Obviously, our playgrounds, our benches,
our trash cans, our pavilions, and all those things—the high, the most visual
things are the first things that we put in there and we're trying to manage
that. But what that's gonna do is that's gonna kick out a maintenance
or a replacement schedule long-term too.
And we have to be careful. And the other thing I wanna bring up is
after these amenities are installed,
we can't use impact fee dollars to replace them. It's general
fund dollars that will replace these. Impact fee dollars can only be
used when we're developing or we're continuing that level of service in
the community. So I think it's just important to make sure that we distinguish those
pots of dollars and where they'll come from. But every time that we add
a park in the community, we gotta make sure that we
have that longevity in it built into it that we can replace it over a
long-term period of time. So I just wanted to add that for the record.
Thank you, Brad. And Council Member Whiting, I think
you're right. I mean, look, I would certainly be okay funding some benches sooner rather
than later. With this caveat, I think there's still an opportunity to— because
you can use impact fees to do that. It's a new improvement, right, Brad?
If they don't exist technically, we probably could use that for
them. I think we went on the shorter end on Smith
Ranch because as we— me being heavily involved in the process,
we go through a design process of a park and then we hit a price
threshold, right? Yep. And then you try to figure out how far you can
make your dollar stretch and try to develop this park out. And some,
some things just have to get cut when you're doing a price,
when you're doing value evaluation engineering and you're doing it on the fly.
Like, some things get cut and it's just part of the process.
But I know that it seems small, and but everything in the scheme of the
picture, it adds up. But I like the idea of putting them in
early and then finding someone that wants to donate some money so
that they can memorialize someone that they wanna memorialize and just have
a system in place so that we can just add a little placard or something
to do that to even an existing bench and then allow
those funds to continue to grow and perpetuate upon
themselves where we can then,
rather than an impact fee, those dollars begin to fund some of the
replacement.
So just real quick, I wanted to double-check
with Lacey if it's possible. Rich, do you want to try?
I think maybe the microphone's working.
Do you want to try the other? Yeah, can you
We can move on. How about now? No,
I see him. Yeah, I see him talking and his sound's off, but it's not
coming through. Okay, we'll continue working
the way we have been for a minute. Councilmember Wood or Carson's going to try
and see if we
can— so any other feedback for Jesse and the board? Can I
talk again, Councilmember Wood?
How about now? That rules out that.
I wanna hear who's the Pirates of
Penzance. Nothing. Okay. How about now? So is that
something that you would like the Community Services Board to develop, would be a mechanism
to get either sponsors or memorial benches going? Yeah, I think that would
be cool. And I would say,
I don't know that they necessarily have to be sponsor ones.
Maybe they're memorial or honorary,
honorarium type benches.
I like the idea of us funding our benches, but also having
an opportunity for people who wanna do something for a loved one that's
passed away, so. It's like buying a brick or some of the other projects that
we could do. Is there any other thing that you wanted us to work on?
Like some of those other parks like the— I got
plenty. But I'm happy to add more. The, like, the amphitheater
and some, you know, prioritize some of the other parks, which I think they've been
doing. I don't— just haven't had time to report yet.
I definitely think that should— I'd like to see them take the parks and
prioritize them. What needs to be done at them? How do we get them up
to a service level that we're comfortable with? And then give us the opportunity to
do a funding schedule for them. Yes, I have that written
down. Yep, got that on the list. So, all right,
awesome, good work. Thank you so much. Make sure you tell the rest of the
board that doesn't come every time that we appreciate them too.
Thank you. All right, just sit tight,
Rich. I'm gonna set the phone down long enough that— but you're still with us.
So, uh,
going right along, that's all for our discussion items, and then,
uh, We'll look to our manager Ben for any information
items. Over the weekend, I sent a lot
of information items out to our council in a series of email— emails that I'm
sure was a little bit overwhelming, but we have a lot of great work
going on in our city, citywide, with different projects and planning,
funding undertakings, and infrastructure improvements.
With that said, I just want to extend appreciation to our staff for all the
good work that they do and ask the council if there's any questions that you
have on anything that's been shared. I think just because it's
a work session, this is a good chance to talk about what
we got done today. Yes, if you want.
Yeah, do you want me to talk about it? Yeah, do you want to talk
about— okay, if I find something I need to fill in, I will. Okay,
so, um, today we, we, uh, met, had the opportunity,
uh, to meet with House Speaker Mike Schultz,
and he was very gracious in welcoming us to meet
with him about our transportation needs specifically within our community.
The meeting was set up by our representative Stephanie Grecious,
and she attended that meeting and helped facilitate that for us,
and she did an exceptionally good job. I think there was some,
some maybe fear interpretation walking into that meeting that perhaps we
might come in with tons of demands,
and I think they were very pleasantly surprised that we were coming in
with ideas and solutions on how to meet those demands. That we see ourselves
as being a partner with the state, working on economic development
opportunities, working on transportation and water opportunities,
and recognizing that if we are to continue to grow as a
region, not just Eagle Mountain but Saratoga Springs and West
Lehigh as well, that there has to be transportation
relief to our area. And some of those transportation funding dollars are already
programmed out to 2032 and beyond. And so some
of the ideas were, how can we get state funding
allocated to meet the needs of our area and
do so in a manner that we could either self or work with our
development partners to try to self-fund some of those projects
with state dollars coming in in later years to help program and offset that.
That would benefit us specifically because we would be able to
undertake those projects today and then provide our residents immediate
relief. But second and most important, we would be able to do
it at a less expensive price than it would be to construct in 2030.
2033, 2034. And so if we can do those things up front,
that saves dollars for the state as well over their long term, and it
opens up things for, for our entire region.
The concerns expressed by House Speaker Schultz was that he wants to make
sure that we don't circumvent or break the process. We have processes in the state
of Utah for funding, but in articulating
that the processes that we have had locally have been maybe
a little bit broken to some degree because we have larger geographic areas
with less representation on boards like MAG,
where other parts of the county have smaller municipalities
with lots of mayors and funding can go to different areas.
And everybody wants a bite at the apple, and yet we really need to look
at what are the, what are the roads that are failing
and how do we address those failing roads, and how do we do it in
the most expeditious way possible. And so our
ask was really not to circumvent or earmark or circumvent a
process. It was really how do we fix the process so we can work together
to meet the needs and demands of our area. The mayor
did an exceptionally good job sharing our story that
we're adding as a community more than 200 cars per month,
adding to our overall region when you add Saratoga and
West Lehigh to it, nearly 500 cars per month. And the
programming dollars are already spent. And by the time we hit the next available
funding cycle, we will have 24,000 more cars on
our streets. And sharing that story and laying it out on a map,
but doing so in an empathetic way, saying, look, we, we have a desire to
help the state meet its needs because we want our kids and grandkids to live
near us. We want to have opportunities for them to have homeownership,
single-family homeownership, not necessarily
everybody living in a condo or a townhouse type of thing, but we want them
to have the same opportunities that we had growing up here and living
in Utah. And, and so being able to align
our priorities with the state's priorities and being able to
find solutions along the way turned out to be a very productive
meeting. We certainly appreciate the House Speaker if there's anything
that he maybe appreciated the most is that, is that
we were direct. We came to him with solutions.
We weren't trying to necessarily lobby things from him, but we were
trying to find solutions together in partnership with him and,
and do so on face value to meet the demands of our community.
And so the mayor did a great job. Stephanie did a great job.
David and Evan were both there. They did a great job. I just sat in
the I sat back and watched them all, and I was just glad to be
part of an exceptionally good group. I think going into that,
Speaker Schultz was probably, yeah, everybody's got needs, and what makes yours
more important than the others? By the time we got halfway through the meeting,
he extended our time by almost double,
stayed and visited with us, and said, you know, we've really got to address this,
and kind of got on board with we've got to figure this out.
As David has pointed out, I think our current funding for things
like Lake Mountain Road is 2033 to 2045,
roughly. Well, Lake Mountain's not even funded right
now. It's currently in plans. The Phase 2 is the '33
to '42. Yeah, so that's Phase 2 of SR 73, and I think we've shown
that both those roads will get done before, you know,
we need those or we can't continue. I think we made headway,
you know, on some of the things that we were trying to do. So I
just wanted to make that report and let you know that we'll just
keep the foot on the gas pedal, I guess. I think they were pleasantly surprised
because I really feel like they were maybe a little nervous and a little— Yeah,
what makes us different? A little defensive, maybe a little nervous
about meeting with us. And I think they left feeling like we were partners.
I thought it was a very positive meeting. And making us stand
out to why are we different than everybody else that also has needs, but we
were able to identify why. So I think that's, we're going
in the right direction. So anyway, any questions
on those meetings specifically, comments? No? Okay.
Any other update items? They're in the emails, right?
Ben? I think that's it. That's it? Okay.
Then let's go on to the consent agenda real quick.
Let's
see. So there's
a proclamation on 9A that I was just looking at, and I'm wondering if
Councilmember Whiting wants to read this when we get to that. I'd be— I'd be
happy to. Okay, I got it here. Then, uh,
we will go to the change orders, which were Mr.
Salazar. Yep, I can have—
I have a presentation I included, and I'm happy to go through it if there
are questions, or if we're good with it, we can just move forward.
No questions. And Council Member Wood, I think he's
still here. No question. And for the record, that will close out the No questions.
Okay, uh, minutes September
1st. Nothing.
Uh, preliminary site plans. This is, uh, Mr. Lemons is back
there. Is there any questions or presentation?
No? Anything? So one item I had on, on the— I know
this is on the consent agenda, but there is a Planning Commission recommendation
for Spring Run Plaza Lot 2. And so
I think when we make the consent agenda approval, we probably want
to call that out specifically, that the PC recommendation is also— just
so everyone's aware what that is, make sure they agree. What was the— I'd
have to look it up. That was just my notes. Now we got to go
take a look deeper, but whatever it was, I liked it.
So did everybody else— do we want to just pull it off of the consent
consent agenda since we have such a— No, no, you can make the motion.
I'll read, I'll read it for you. It says the Planning Commission
forwarded a positive recommendation to City Council for the Spring Run Plaza Lot 2 site
plan with the following conditions: the east elevation be clad in
at least 60% high-quality natural materials. Staff note that the applicant
has since updated the east elevation to contain at least 60% high-quality natural
materials. And the shared parking and maintenance agreement be filed
with staff as as part of the site plan application. And as I read it,
it's 2 parking spaces that they're short on too that
they wanna share with Lot 1. Yeah, and it's really, so they, of those conditions,
Condition 1 has since been met. So it's Condition 2 that is
the shared parking and maintenance agreement. So you're okay with
that? Yeah. Yeah. Recommend, okay. You're good. Yeah, you're good. So as noted,
we'll just make that into the motion.
15A, resolution of Eagle Mountain approving the agreement with Utah
Public Solutions LLC to provide lobbying services.
No question? Pretty straightforward on that? Well, okay, so the question
I have, so I guess maybe this was just included in the material, but I
think pages 5 and 6 were the submission from the
lobbyist with the terms he wanted, is my guess,
because the terms, the term that was in 5 and 6 was different.
The dollar amount requested in pages 5 and 6 were also different
than what was in the actual contract. So I guess, was that just provided to
us for our visual reading, and that's not actually incorporated
into the overall agreement because the term and the, the pricing were different?
Right, the, the pricing is what's part of our agreement. Um,
the, the $40,000, that pricing was negotiated afterwards
after receiving that The proposal was brought in as
an exhibit more to help delineate what the scope of
his specific offerings will be as far as what he'll
contribute to our needs as a city, not necessarily the
cost proposal that's part of there. And his— he
needs to update GOEO to GOED as well,
'cause that was outdated. True, yes.
So is it identified which one is approved in the consent agenda if they're different?
I know the answer, but it's the $40,000? Yes.
Okay.
He'd requested, I think,
$80-some-odd thousand. If it was full-time services, but we've got
them on a job-specific, and so that's what what
the change was. I just want to make sure that the contracts— we're comfortable
with the way the wording is. Yeah.
Um,
just did you have another comment, Council Member Wood?
If no, I had one quick— I had one question. I was just trying
to remember what it was. It was actually not I don't have a question specific
to the site plan for the
one over on Spring Run, but I saw something that I wanted our staff to
take a look at, and you reminded me about it when we talked about a
drive-through. There is a restaurant that I believe is in American
Fork or Pleasant Grove where they have a double drive-through that helps
to accommodate some of the problems with having multiple drive— or multiple fast
food places in a small area. The name of the restaurant is Tava,
I believe. I'd love for you guys to take a look at that and see
if there's a way we could implement something like that for some of these smaller
parcels where they want to do those drive-throughs.
What was the name of the restaurant? Tava. It's an Italian
restaurant. Italian restaurant Tava.
T-A-V-A. Okay, thank you.
We can look into that. We'll look at that during the break.
Um, the next one, 15B, right? Is that where you said we were? Uh,
Mr. Draper, that's the Spring Run Partners,
uh, reimbursement agreement. Yeah, this is
in relation to upsizing that's being required by the city for
that development. The lion's share of that is the upsizing of Wagstaff
Way. So which will increase certain
construction costs. Additionally, there is some upsizing
of water pipes and stormwater and wastewater
pipes, but that would take the balance of
the agreement. This is just the terms of the agreement as far as us reimbursing
them for the upsize. Any questions on that one?
Okay, we're good. The other
one— I just want to be clear, Mayor. I mean,
you wrote this, Marcus. I just want to make sure this is clear, that this
agreement would not cover the cost of purchasing the additional land for the wider
road. Yeah, that's coming at a later date in a future agreement.
Just wanted to make sure that— Yeah, this is just for the construction costs for
the developer. It's not the purchase of the land from the landowner. Just— that's
clear. I wanted to make sure that was clear. Thank you. OK,
now there's one scheduled item. We do have a little bit of time,
I think, before we're ready for break, so I do know
that there are probably some clarification and things would be good to talk about this.
Is that all right? On the budget amendment. So Terrence, if you would
like to present this. This has to do with our first
annual budget amendment. There are a couple of
things that we definitely wanna make sure to get in this budget
amendment. One of them was Silver Lake or Woodhaven, but the roundabout
there at the bottom of Silver Lake, I believe. And it's a design.
Yeah, so Terrence has some slides he's gonna pull up. We can talk through this.
So we can, yeah, we'll just wait until you get there 'cause I know it's
probably to the end.
Mayor and Council, I don't know if you want me to do the full presentation
later since there's a public hearing, but I can touch on some of the changes
between what's in the packet and— I think the highlights, and, and maybe just,
uh, because I do want to see the presentation one for the public hearing.
Sounds good. So jump to the highlights. Okay,
so pretty much, um,
I sent you an email this morning about, um, a couple more projects needed
to be added on the budget amendment for tonight. Those are the
eagle— some leftover money for the Eagle Monument project,
the digital sign info, and also the fencing
for the wildlife corridor, which is tied to a grant project as well.
Um, I'll go over— sorry,
aside from those rollover projects which already approved
before There are 3 more projects that will be added for
the budget amendment discussion for today's, um, tonight, today's meeting.
The first one will be the Pony Express Widening Phase 1 construction. That will
be from Eagle Mountain Boulevard to Shadow Drive.
The amount being requested is about $1.8 million,
and the construction is planned to be starting on February
2027. Um,
part of that project is removing the median and also going from 2
to 5 lanes, so a widening project. And then the next one will be Pony
Express, which is the Phase 2. The design— the proposed is
to put some funding for $250,000 for the design for
this project, from 3 to 5 lanes,
adding some improvement for traffic signals and also realigning
some of the Paul Canyon Boulevard and the Point Express intersection
as well. So this one, the Phase 2, will cover from
Shadow Drive to Public Works area.
And then the last one is the Silver Lake Neighborhood Improvement
Design. There is a proposal of $250,000
for the design plan for this fall. This is,
uh, to do roundabout removals from the
Woodhaven and Silver Lake area, and also Golden Eagle and Silver Lake to
become Woodhaven, to replace the traffic signal and also do
some realignment with road and crosswalks as well. If you
have any question, I have David here as well. Would you go back
to the fence and trail? I didn't know how those were related, so I
was curious. I think it was 220. $25,000 maybe?
Let me open up the— sorry, it will be a lot easier
to see it from here. Let's see.
Wildlife fencing.
Give me one second. It's opening up. All right, you've got it right there on
the right. New asphalt trail, Walden Park to Cedar Corners.
I don't know if that's the same one, and that's why I'm confused.
Give me one second. Sorry. There you go.
I don't know if it's big enough, but let me make it a little bit
bigger. The one that I
emailed this morning is the additional money,
about $474,000, and that will Let
me just find the exact one.
So this is the new— let me just— It was on the same line
item with the— Yes.
The first one will be the $6,800 for the leftover for
the Eagle Monument, and that is to cover some of the landscaping portion of
that project, and it's about to be done sooner.
And then the next one is the— it was part of the budget
amendment from last fiscal year, the $268,000 for the digital
sign projects, and just— we're just rolling
it over for this current fiscal year. And then there is a
grant money that we got through the Division of Wildlife Resources that Todd
was working before. That's about $200,000 also
that could be rolled over for this current fiscal year.
So these are the 3 projects that— That makes sense. In the email it said
that it included a trail, and I didn't know how the trail was,
was, uh, correlated with that because they're kind of different areas,
but maybe it was different. So my other Question
or clarification, Brad or Zach could maybe weigh in.
It's right there if you leave it on line 88,
basically the asphalt trail from Walden Park to Cedar Corners.
Do you need to include from
Cedar Corners to— Mayor, are you referring to
this $25,000 project later? I don't think we need to adjust
anything really. I think really what we're trying to here in
the fund is obviously we received some grant money for this project,
correct? Mm-hmm. And this is showing that we have an expenditure account
so that we can bill the resources and the materials against it.
We just, we just need it for bookkeeping and whatnot. So,
and then once we submit all the funds, whatever we
end up using on that, which we anticipate we'll use the full $25,000
on that project, then we would submit that for reimbursement.
But it's just really— it's an expenditure account that we have to show
that we can spend the dollars for the project.
Any other questions as to what was in our packet? We'll wait
for the public hearing for the rest. If there isn't, let me make sure.
Councilmember Wood, did you have any other questions on this?
If you didn't stop me, I'm going to assume you're good. No, I don't.
OK, perfect. The training—
Mayor, before we move on from this, I know that
as we are traveling today, we are talking about some potential changes
that would come maybe potentially by motion. Would you like David— That's— they're
in here. That's the ones we just talked about. The Woodhaven— that was the— that
was the Silver Lake and then the the, uh, Point Express,
the waiting, the design. Yes,
they were in there. So as it's presented, we'll,
uh, either by motion or as presented. Uh, the next one was
the 17A, the training. Marcus, does that need to wait for the next meeting,
or can we do that right now? We've got 20 minutes, maybe. It's going to
take more than 20 minutes, so we'll talk fast.
This is, uh, annual training on open public Meetings
Act as well as municipal ethics law. Can we start
it and continue? Go ahead. Mayor, we are talking about—
we have a portion of our closed meeting that would need to start at 6
o'clock because of other attendees, but there
we could cover other things prior to and maybe take care of all
of those things so that we don't necessarily need to come back after the entire—
If we can get it all done, that's what I was trying to either do,
this one or that, and I'm I think it makes sense
to use the time for closed session. Okay. In that case,
I'm open for motion. I move that the council adjourn to a closed session pursuant
to Section 52-4-205, subsection 1
of the Utah Code Annotated. Second. All right.
We have a motion by Councilmember Whiting and a second by Councilmember Wright. And I'm
going to start the vote with Councilmember Clark. Yes.
Councilmember Wright? Yes. Councilmember Whiting? Yes. Councilmember Wood?
Yes. Yes. All right, we'll adjourn at 5:36 to a closed session
and be back at 7:00. And, and we will start sending a
link to Rich. Yeah, he's got it. All right.
Good. Stephanie's good.
Okay. All right. Before we get started,
Councilmember Wright is going to offer a prayer.
Our Heavenly Father, we're grateful to bow our heads in prayer on this Tuesday evening.
We express gratitude to live in this free country and this beautiful city and,
and to be citizens one with
another. And we pray thy Spirit be upon us as we consider those matters
of business that will come before the council tonight, that we'll be kind,
respectful, listen, and be
able to disagree without being disagreeable and express our
opinions and Amen. Pray for any that may choose to offer public
comment or engage the council or the mayor on, on any
level this evening, that, that they'll feel heard and have that
opportunity to express their thoughts and feelings and help us to
have listening ears and feeling hearts. We express
gratitude for our first responders. Pray thy protection and
safety upon them, as well as our military military families and veterans as
we, as we know that they find themselves in harm's way
from time to time. Help us to be neighborly and look after one another.
These things we kindly ask in the name of Jesus Christ. Amen.
All right, thank you. It is 7:03, and I'll officially
call this policy session to order.
Before we get started, I just wanted to mention Councilmember Hewish
and Councilmember Wood have been excused. They have some prior obligations. There's a
chance we'll get Councilmember Wood remotely, but maybe
not. Looks like he's off for the night. So we
appreciate all of you guys that have made it here. And it is the 15th
of September, 7:03. And as we
get started, we'll have Deputy St. Peter lead
us in the Pledge of Allegiance.
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States
of America, and to the republic for which it stands,
one nation Under God, indivisible,
with liberty and justice for all.
Thank you.
You kind of acted like that was a surprise, but everything we do around here
is throwing you right in the fire. So thank you.
Start off, there's actually— I know of a couple of things,
but hopefully Steve's ready. From what I understand,
there's a couple of information items. I was at a UFA meeting this morning.
Um, Chief— or, uh, I almost called you Chief Perchet.
That's pretty good, right? You just want his pay too, right? Chief Fossum was
there with me, and we learned some cool stuff. And I know as a city
we've, uh, been working on some, uh, e-bike regulations
and different things like that. So, uh, go ahead.
So, um, as I'm— as Steve is coming up to, uh,
show that video, I'll go over the other information items if that's okay while he
gets set up. We'll just need to have the thing
set up there. Some of the other events coming up this week is Days
of Service, Tuesday, September 15th through Thursday, September 17th.
So look for your opportunities to volunteer and serve throughout
our community to make a difference. Fall dumpsters are coming Wednesday,
September 16th through Wednesday, September 23rd at Quarry Ride Park.
And so it's a great time to clean up your
homes prior to winter. Eagle Mountain Academy begins Wednesday, September 16th.
This is our Citizens Academy, and we're excited to bring our 4th cohort through
and to share what goes on in our city.
Utah Rotor Pathway Fly-In, Friday,
September 18th, from 4:30 to 6:30 PM at Cedar
Valley High School. A helicopter will be landing at 4 PM.
There's a farmers market, of course, every Saturday from 9 AM to
1 PM through October 10th at Cory-Royd Park.
There's an adaptive trick-or-treat Saturday, October 3rd,
from 2 PM to 4 PM at City Hall. And then our movie
in the park Saturday, October 3rd, 7 to 9 PM at Cory-Royd Park.
That is the memorial park featuring Hocus Pocus.
And with that, I'll turn it over to Steve to play this video. We're going
to watch Hocus Pocus.
We know e-bikes and scooters are becoming more and more popular in our communities,
especially with our kids. Unfortunately, we're seeing a significant
increase in the number of injuries with riding e-bikes and scooters.
We want to get your attention. E-bikes and e-scooters
are not toys. They are vehicles.
Here at Unified Fire Authority, we want to make sure that everybody understands
the risks of riding, knows how to ride safely, and has the
proper safety equipment and wears it every time they ride.
Riding a traditional bike requires physical effort to build speed.
E-bikes and e-scooters are different. They provide a lot more power
with little to no effort, making it easier to reach higher
speeds. That combination of speed and minimal
effort can make it harder to recognize how much risk you're
taking and how quickly things can change. More speed means less
time to react, which can lead to very serious injuries,
especially when not wearing a helmet. In 2025
alone, Intermountain Healthcare emergency rooms across Utah treated 536
people for e-bike and e-scooter injuries. Furthermore, only about
40% of bike trauma patients were wearing a helmet at
the time of their crash. A new state law is now in effect requiring e-bike
and e-scooter riders under 21 to wear an approved helmet when riding on public
roads. Ideally, a full-face helmet, which offers the most
protection. These statistics are concerning, but there are steps
we can take to avoid many of these accidents and injuries.
So, what can we do about it?
Parents, pay close attention to the e-bikes and scooters your child
is riding. Make sure it's appropriate for their age.
Helmet on every ride, every time,
no exception. Teach your kids to follow traffic laws and signs,
ride at a safe speed, and always stay alert to what's happening around
them. At intersections and crosswalks, teach them to yield to
drivers and pedestrians, never blow through an intersection,
and make sure both parties can see each other before proceeding.
Make sure they're wearing visible clothing and have proper lights, especially in
low-light conditions. These simple steps can help
keep our kids safe every time they ride.
Remember, e-bikes and scooters are not toys. They are
vehicles. So let's all work together to make sure that our
kids make it home safely every time.
Chief Fossum, we— this is a great video. Is the OFEA
okay if we put this on our website and also post it
on our Facebook page? Great, thank you.
Yes, I just wanted to bring that— something that we looked at this morning.
I know as we look at code, also at safety, I think it's
just a good reminder to teach our kids,
first of all, that helmets are required under 18 on e-bikes, just like motorcycles,
under 21, and that they're not toys or vehicles.
So the, as a reminder, as we kind of, I think
this is just an evolving situation, the e-bike situation.
So anytime we get good information like that, I think we can bring it to
the public and share, so. Thank you. Wanted to bring that out.
With that, we have introduction.
You're good, Mayor Council.
Mr. Reeves, thank you. Before I introduce one of our newest deputies,
I was going to introduce both of them, and I'll publicly apologize to Deputy St.
Peter. He was not ready to come here and give the Pledge of Allegiance.
So, um, but, but thank you to him for that.
Before I get into that introduction, just let me first thank you, all of
you, and Eagle Mountain staff for all the hard work they've put in over the
last several months for, you know, especially dealing with some of these financial decisions that
needed to be made and, and, uh, and that you guys have worked through.
So thank you. Um, and again, on behalf of the Sheriff's Office,
thank you very much for that. So let me call up Deputy Deputy Cunningham.
So in the past, as I've done, I just want you guys
to meet some of our newest deputies. We have a lot of newest— new deputies.
St. Peter has been here for a little over a year. He comes to the
table with experience. But tonight I wanted you to meet Deputy Cunningham.
She's new out here to Eagle Mountain. She is not new to law enforcement.
Her career kind of started in dispatch many years ago. She spent about 8 years
in dispatch and And she spent 5-plus years on patrol with
another agency. During that time, she was involved with criminal
investigations, special victims investigations. She was part of the traffic unit. She is currently motor
certified, and I think she's been authorized to ride our bikes already.
Close to it? Close to it. Close to it. So we'll get her certified as
another motorcycle rider here in Eagle Mountain with one of the 2 bikes
that we have out here available to them. So you might see her out here
doing some traffic enforcement. Some of you may have met her already. I'm not
sure if you've met her in that context yet,
but— Anyways, I just wanted to introduce
you to her and to the citizens of Eagle Mountain. I think she's super excited.
We are super excited to have her. She comes to the table with a wealth
of knowledge, with a lot of experience, and is a great addition to our team
out here in Eagle Mountain. So welcome.
Yeah, I'd say, I'd say welcome for sure. I've already had the opportunity to
do— I can't even remember what we've done, but you've helped me on some calls
already, and luckily you haven't been the one to pull me over yet.
So, although it has happened, and it's a great challenge to pull the mayor over.
So it's just a matter of time. I got pulled over last week pulling
into City Hall of all places. Again, thank you guys,
and I thank all of you, and thank you, Deputy. Appreciate it. Appreciate it.
Thank you. Yeah, welcome. We love our
guys, our law enforcement, and we've had a lot of things.
But yeah, I think so. You're afraid of this one?
No, you were going to— Oh, I was just going to say,
I think we should clap to welcome you to our city.
All right, thank you. The next item on our agenda
is 9A, the proclamation of Eagle Mountain City proclaiming Eagle Mountain as a just-served
city, right around the corner with 9/11. Craig's going to read the
proclamation. Okay, proclamation proclaiming Eagle
Mountain City as a just-served city.
Whereas Eagle Mountain City, Utah recognizes that volunteers
are an essential part Part of a strong, connected, and thriving
community. And whereas meaningful volunteer service
provides opportunities for residents to build relationships,
develop a greater sense of belonging, meet community needs, and make a positive
difference in the lives of others. And whereas JustServe is
a service that connects individuals and organizations with meaningful volunteer
opportunities in their local communities, helping people find ways to serve.
According to their interests, abilities, and availability, and whereas
Eagle Mountain City desires to encourage and strengthen
volunteerism throughout the community and to help residents discover opportunities
to serve their neighbors and improve the quality of life in Eagle Mountain,
and whereas the city recognizes that service is most
powerful when residents, organizations, businesses,
and community partners work together toward the common good,
And whereas designating Eagle Mountain City as a JustServe
City demonstrates the city's commitment
to promoting volunteerism, connecting residents with opportunities to
serve, and supporting organizations that seek to make a positive difference
in our community. Now therefore, be it proclaimed
that Mayor Jared Gray and the Eagle Mountain City Council
do hereby designate Eagle Mountain City as a JustServe
city and encourage residents, organizations,
businesses, and community partners to participate
in meaningful service opportunities throughout our community.
Dated this 15th day of September, 2026.
OK, thank you, Craig. Marcus, just as a reminder,
proclamation executive, or do we need to accept that by motion?
I think historically we have just done it
as an executive proclamation. Okay.
Well, it's included in the consent agenda, isn't it?
Or no? No. Okay. That's why I was wondering if it needed to be.
Just executive? I think that's what we've done historically. I think
we should continue with what we've always done. Okay, be it done.
Um, next item is, uh,
public comment. Time has been set aside for the public to express their ideas,
concerns, and comments. As a reminder, public comment is an opportunity
for the community members to address the city council, and each speaker is allowed
up to 3 minutes. If you wish to speak during the public comment portion,
please complete the comment form located in the back of the room and return it
to our city recorder, Lacey, on this side.
Council members will listen but not engage in discussion during public comment. We ask
that everyone remain respectful. Disruptive behavior,
including cheering, booing, clapping, or comments directed at individual city
employees, is prohibited. If you have an issue or question regarding staff or personnel,
administrative staff will meet you in the foyer for further discussion.
Lastly, public comment period is for items not associated with the scheduled
public hearing. If your comment relates to a public hearing item, please wait
until that item is called. And tonight's public hearing items
are 16A, resolution and public hearing of Eagle
Mountain City approving the first amendment to the fiscal year 2026-2027
annual budget. So that one we will call in just
a few minutes. Right now I will open the public comment period at 7:16
and ask if if there's anyone here. I do have Brianne
Salazar. She noted 16A but also wanted to comment on
17A. 16A is a public hearing.
OK, 16A we can wait, but 17A is fine.
Brianne Salazar.
We will allow you to come back again on 17, just so you know.
You get 3 minutes, but in the public hearing you'll you'll get a chance again.
So you will get a chance to speak again in '16.
Make sure the mic is on. There you go.
Okay, so I am Brianne Salazar.
So I just have a couple of questions, and I
know you can't answer my questions, but the one question
that I have is, one, why do you think
Do we pray? Why do we not have a clear designation of church and state?
That is concerning to me as a non-prayerful
person. That is troubling.
Second, I just want to state that I hope
or would ask that we do not.
approve the property tax. And then
I also ask that we stop having data
centers come into Eagle Mountain. So as a resident
that's just further up towards city center, I just
ask that we stop having data centers come in.
So that's all that I have. So thank you.
Thank you.
So Joy Rasmussen as well, general comments, and then the public hearing
comment for 16A.
Hello, I'm here once again to ask, I heard the
news that Meta is building a bunch more data centers, and I'm not sure if
those had been approved, like, a long time ago,
or that was just like a recent thing. But the sentiment I'm
hearing from everybody I know, most everybody, not everybody, but most
everybody, is they're very concerned about building more and more data centers,
that it's taking up so much land, and that's what we're going to be known
for. That's going to affect our property values. There's lots of— it's very unpopular
right now, data centers. And they're getting these deals
to not pay very much property tax, which doesn't feel fair when you're raising
it for us. And so I'm asking you again to please issue
like a resolution that you will stop approving data
centers until like safety measures have been taken to protect us. Like there's
a lot of talk about AI being dangerous, and that's what these data
centers are for. They're not for like just going on Facebook. They're all doing AI.
And there's a lot of concerns about like the infrasound. So there's sound that you
can't actually hear, but your body feels. And it damages your heart,
people living near them are gonna be damaged by these data centers. It takes a
bunch of energy, and it just feels
kind of backwards to be raising our property taxes and giving these data centers the
deals. So maybe if you were like publicly disclosed all the deals and showed the
citizens like, hey, here's why they're benefiting us, like we've mentioned before, that might
be a better way to do it before you announce a bunch of new data
centers. Like, take citizens' input. And the second
thing is I'm going to ask that you repeal the property tax increase because,
um, we haven't been given the line-by-line budget numbers
properly. Um, the pamphlet is inaccurate that we were given
by the city. Um, the pamphlet says it would be on the ballot August 27—
August of 2027, but the code says it should be on this coming November election
if it gets enough signatures. So that's inaccurate. We've emailed the, the recorder
to ask you to correct the pamphlet. I'm asking you guys to respond to that
email and correct the— there's a lot of things that are inadequate or inaccurate according
to law. So that's all I have to say. Thank you.
Missy Perry.
Just kind of piggybacking off of Joy Rasmussen, my name is Missy
Perry. This is the first meeting I've come to.
I've I've lived here for about 6 years, and I feel like
you need to represent the citizens and
also listen to the concerns that we have. And I
find it incredibly concerning what has been happening recently in
our city. I would like there to
be a clear, concise outline of
the budget, of the allocations of funds regarding
our budget, and why the property tax increase has occurred.
I want that to be put on the ballot to be
voted on or either repealed because citizens have a right to choose.
This is affecting my family. This is going to affect my future
children. And I just want to see on the budget, I want to
see the proof of your work. Where did you come up with this? What did
you— did you look into other budgets to cut things, to kind
of cut the fat to put money into other things
to allocate that to help with what we need for public
safety. Because I'm not against public safety or anything, even though that's been
purported like throughout the media. Like, that's— I
want to support the fact that we have an increased need for public,
um, like police or a couple more deputies
and whatnot. However, I want to see the proof of your work.
I want to see where on the budgets we couldn't cut things.
So, um, I want a line-by-line thing. I would
like to see something similar to what, um, Saratoga Springs has
and what they have shown their citizens. And I find it very concerning
that every time it's brought up, it's deleted from the city citizens page.
It's deleted, um, on all these different forums where
usually we all come together and It's just very concerning to
me that this is happening here in our town,
and I'm having to come here in
person and say, please just show me your work, show me the
physical proof, because the links that are provided are not adequate at all.
Thank you for your time.
I do want to clarify that she did also request 16A, so we'll
come back And that's all I have right now.
Okay, is there anyone else that is here that came to speak
in our public comment period that did not get an
opportunity? Seeing no one, we will close our public comment period at
7:23, and we'll bring it back to
the council. But I can answer a couple of quick questions. Marcus can help me
on some of this. The question about the ballot. The county
required— they're already printing ballots. They get mailed out in a couple
of weeks. For us to say whether or not the referendum would be— would
have the signatures on the ballot, we don't know that answer yet. So what the
law actually says is that we can hold a special election.
Yeah, it says that it'll be held the next regular municipal election,
whichever is earlier, unless a special election is called.
So the intent would be to call a special election In the event it qualifies
for a ballot, right? There's no way to get it on the ballot because we
don't have the signatures yet, and it's already required to be into the county right
now. So given the signatures, it will be an item that will be voted on.
It'll just be voted on at the appropriate time with the next election.
I think that's
most of what I'm going to address right now. I'm happy to address any of
the other concerns or questions. After the meeting,
so with that, we'll bring it back to the council and Melissa
Councilman Clark. Thanks, Mayor. Thank you for being here tonight.
It's fun to see first responders and some of our residents
coming and sharing their thoughts about what's going on with the city and the questions
that they have. If I could, I would
sit down with you each on your front porch and talk to you about some
of the decisions. decisions that we've made and help you see just
some of our reasons behind them. So if you have questions, please reach
out. It's very difficult to conduct a conversation on Facebook
with people. So, um,
that— I also want to thank our tiny,
tiny army of staff that has
done so many great things this summer with us.
Between water pipes busting and wells going
down and having to write
and do huge packets and to
do the publicity and information
about different events and answer questions.
And I really wanted to acknowledge Evan Barrett.
10 years ago, our city had an intern that thought
it would be a really cool idea to have a street fair so that there
would be a place for our small businesses to be able to go and
sell what they make to our neighbors. And that street
fair grew to the point where it didn't fit on the street anymore.
And it was really, really cool. We liked that street because it was shaded and
there were lots of trees there. But this weekend That
street fair celebrated its 10th anniversary,
and, um, none of that would have happened
without Evan Barrett's dedication and foresight
and drive to help support our small businesses
in our community. And Evan, I just want to thank you for all that you've
done to help economic development and our small businesses.
So thank you.
Thanks, Mayor. Welcome. It's good to see so many who've come
out tonight. Just want to express my gratitude to each of you for taking
the time to come and to share your thoughts. Even if we have a difference
of opinion or we understand things perhaps from a little different perspective,
I'm always grateful to, to have those who see things
differently to help me see things from a different perspective. I want
to, uh, I, I want to, I want to highlight Mayor Gray. He's not
expecting this, He doesn't know this. I'm probably going to embarrass him, and I'm
going to do it on purpose, okay?
I just want to express my gratitude for the work that he has been doing.
He has been running around Utah.
He's been running around the nation and meeting with anybody
and everybody whose ear he can get to try and help
us advance those things that matter to Eagle Mountain. Citizens.
He spent some time— and look,
I know there are some who will say, well, gosh, why are you doing
that? We're doing it because we're trying to improve our situation.
I know he's met with Senator Curtis, with Congressman
Kennedy. Certainly he met with the Speaker of the House today,
Mike Schultz, and he's talked with Stuart Adams, our Senate President,
worked with our local representatives,
both House and Senate. And I just, I don't
think the citizens really see the work that goes into what
our mayor does. He's a cowboy at heart.
He's used to getting up at 4:00 AM and taking clients on a hunt.
And he works hard all day. He rides his horse, which anybody
that's ridden a horse knows how much fun that is or isn't.
I don't do it, can't do it. Some of you here do
and enjoy that. But I just, I wish that
each of you could spend 24 hours with him and just see
the effort that he's putting forth on your behalf. I think that the way you
feel about him and perhaps this council would start to
change and modify a little bit if you really understood the work that
we are about. So thank you, Mayor Gray, for your leadership, your example,
and for your advocacy. advocacy, and in spite of
your many imperfections, which are smaller than mine,
I just am grateful for you and for the efforts you've been putting forward.
Thank you for those who made public comment. One invitation
I'll extend is I'm very happy to meet with any of you who have concerns
or questions that were brought up. It would be a lot easier to
to go through and answer the questions in person,
on Zoom, whatever, live. It'd be a lot easier than
in an email or text messaging or definitely, or like
instant messaging, whatever it may be. And I've extended that invitation to any who's had
questions. Some residents have taken the opportunity to meet with me.
And those of you who presented today, I'm happy to meet with you as well
to ensure that your questions are all answered. and that
understanding could be provided back and forth.
So I'm very happy to listen and to share
what I can. So just reach out to me individually. I'm happy to set up
a private, or you can make it public if you want to bring people as
well, that's fine. I'm happy to meet with whoever you wanna meet with, so,
or have come and join on that. Grateful to be part of this great city.
And, you know, we,
This city has significant opportunity,
and in many ways there's a blank
canvas before us more than any other kind of city that's here in Utah.
And so with that, there comes great responsibility that we guide it in a way
that it becomes a prosperous city for all, not just for
a few, but for all. And as a council, we feel the burden to make
sure that the way we develop the city and grow it and and nurture
it, it's done in a way that is with a lot of foresight
and that we are contemplative of the various opportunities
and to make sure we execute those in the best way possible to bring the
greatest amount of prosperity possible to the greatest amount of people.
It's really our endeavor as a council.
We dive into the details. We research. We struggle,
we debate back and forth, we listen to a lot of people.
One thing that's opened my eyes is before
I got elected, I was warned that it was going to take quite a bit
of time. The warnings were not strong enough. It takes a lot of
time, a lot more time than I anticipated, and it's weightier
than I anticipated. It's also very rewarding. It's also
very challenging. Thank you. But it's weighty because we
are trying to do something that has not been done. We are trying to create
something that has not been created, and we're trying to elevate this city to a
place that no one thought it could go.
It's going to take a lot of energy and drive to do that. I can
tell you that as what Councilmember Wright just said about our mayor,
that it's true. Mayor Gray is leading from the front,
and it's also true that we are We endeavor to take this city to
a place that no one thought it could ever go. When I say we,
it's not just the City Council. The staff is on board with this,
and citizens.
We're grateful for public participation,
public input, and ideas that come from the citizenry.
Your ideas will help us be stronger and better. I can tell you we are
going to go places that no one thought we could go. We will accomplish things
that people thought could never be accomplished, because we're going to
think larger than other people have thought. I'm grateful that we can be a
part of this great society that is and will be.
Thank you. It's my privilege to have a little bit of time,
so I'll save it for this. I will say that it's a lot
more time than we expected. I know the Morandis are here tonight. I used to
ride horses every Monday and Wednesday. Since I've been elected. I think I've
been twice, but I only remember once. So they can attest
that my riding has been on the back burner.
Going back to— I saved this for the personal time— to some of the questions.
I just want to say this the way that I say it every time.
Before I open the meeting, I say, as is our
tradition, we'll start with a prayer. Then I call the meeting to order.
That's before the meeting. It's something that happens before we
start. And that's by
design. So I wanted to answer that question. The other thing about
the line-by-line budget and stuff like that,
I mean, Craig just told you the hundreds and hundreds
of hours that are recorded and posted. And you're
welcome to look at it. We try to answer every question we can individually.
I'm not saying that. We answer the best we can. They're posted in 300
pages of books that we've attached to the website.
I mean, we have done our best to show everything
we can in the budget, and we'll continue to do that.
A lot of citizens tell us, I don't want to read 300 pages and
go to thousands of hours of meetings. I expect you guys to do it.
That's what we've done. Thank you. happy to sit down
and go through every bit of why and how and what we
arrived at and discuss that, because I think that's
the other part of our job, is helping others understand the Cliff Notes version of
why we did what we did. And that will help us all get
to a better place and a better understanding.
Just to add to some of the other things, I'm grateful for Shop Fest,
the way that went off. I spent a few hours there in the morning before
I had to go to some other things. And then also the farmer's market that
for 3 years in a row, I think I haven't been to everyone, but I've
been to a lot of farmer's markets the last 3 years. And it,
man, it has grown this year. It is unreal how big.
And all the vendors are saying the best market around. They go to other markets
and they're like, we go to Eagle Mountain and some of the others, but they
love this one. So great opportunities in our city. And a lot of that to
our staff. Evan started some of those ideas and we appreciate those going forward
as well as, I mean, the park staff that's shown up this year. The market's
been amazing thanks to those guys every Saturday coming in. The other
thing you mentioned, the Rotary stuff, with that, the reason that's happening is
it's homecoming week. So just a special highlight with our kids at
the high school. Be watching out at the restaurants, they're probably going to be all
dressed up. But the homecoming game Friday night, if you get
a chance to come out, I'm going to go. I've been a couple of football
games already. It's super fun. Just love supporting those kids. So just
remember some of those other activities that are out there. But we appreciate
you guys coming and helping us with perspective and being part
of the process. It really is— it takes all of us. And I can't wait
until I get to sit back down there and maybe start riding on Mondays again.
So welcome to run and come and do this job.
It's a lot of work. So thank you. Thank you. Thank you for being a
part of it. With that, we have a few
items in our consent agenda. I hope you guys made notes 'cause I know there's
a couple changes, but we did talk
about most of these. There was the 14B,
right, had a change, and then I thought there was one more
in— It was just the one. Which one? I think
that's it. Okay, okay, with that
then, Unless there's discussion, will entertain a motion. Mayor, I, uh, I move that
the Eagle Mountain City Council approve the consent agenda, uh, and on
item 14B include the Planning Commission's
recommendation number 2 only.
Second. Okay, we have a motion by Councilman Wright and a second by
Councilmember Whiting, and we'll start the vote with Councilman Wright.
Yes. Councilman Whiting. Yes. Councilmember Clark. Yes.
And just to be sure, Council Member Wood is not online. Okay,
that passes 3 to 0.
And we'll go on to our first scheduled item, item 16A,
resolution— and this is a public hearing— of Eagle Mountain City approving the first amendment
of the fiscal year 2026-2027 annual budget. Uh,
I do know that Terrence has a, a presentation to go over
some of the budget amendments. These are some of the things that we do go
over line by line And he's going to show us some of the things that
we've updated in our budget.
Good evening, Mayor and Council. As mentioned, I'll be going over the first budget
amendment for this current fiscal year. In your packet,
this is the information that you're Currently, it's in the packet,
but as discussed in the work session this afternoon,
there will be some few items that we're adding to the budget amendment.
I'll go them quickly and then we can talk about them in details later on.
The first one is some leftover rollover amount for the Eagle Monument
Project, digital display, wildlife corridor
fencing project, and then we have some transportation project,
widening Pony Express on the south side of the area, the Phase 1
from Eagle Mountain Boulevard to Shadow Drive,
and then from Shadow Drive to Public Works area,
and then some improvements in the Silver Lake area as
well. Um,
I want to provide some context on the requests that we received
for the budget amendment. I'm looking at it capital projects versus operational
budget requests. Majority of the requests, and especially
for this first budget amendment where we just end our fiscal year '26
and we're rolling over to a new fiscal year, um, as you know,
projects tend to span multiple, uh, fiscal years.
So majority of these requests are related to capital projects,
and then about 7% are related to operational,
um, budget requests. If we're looking at capital
projects, um, About 89% are strictly rollovers,
so that means those are previously been approved as part
of the fiscal year 2026 budget. We're just rolling them over, whatever is the leftover,
to continue with the project in this current fiscal year. And then there's about
11% for the new capital project funding requests,
which I will go over in a bit. Now looking
at operational budget requests,
Majority of the requests are tied to vehicles. As you know,
a part of our current fiscal year has approved
some new personnel requests, and then they will need
some vehicles, so we need to purchase those for those individuals.
And then next is equipment. There are quite a few departments
that have requested some equipments that they need, which we, um,
probably using some of the one-time money from the reserves
that we can use for this one. The community development is requesting for a software
to help with their plan reviews, and then there are some
IFA or impact fee analysis, some airport feasibility
study that we need to roll over as part of professional studies.
We also have one personal request in
the general fund. I'll go over that later. And then we have a couple of
programs. We have some rebate money that we receive for our premiums,
which we can use for some safety-related initiatives
for the city and for our employee. And then one of those
programs is tied to the soccer program, which we started
this fall. And then the tiny, tiny blue bar over there is for
the office rental space for the water department, the trailer
mobile office.
Now I'll be going over the items fund
by fund. First is the general fund.
The general fund net change budget request, about $1.4
million. Some of the rollover items, as mentioned,
we started our soccer program this fall,
and then we're— our recreation department is running that program.
So we just want to roll over those approved budget last fiscal year.
Economic Development has some airport feasibility study that
they're doing as well. In terms of new items, as mentioned,
there are some equipment requests from the streets, parks, and open space.
Comes from skid steer— skid steers to some attachments,
some large containers that we can put in the parks as well.
As mentioned, majority of requests are tied to vehicles. And that
rebate money that I mentioned about safety initiatives that we
get from that premium firm rebate stuff. And as mentioned,
we have one personal request, which is to add a
new deputy city recorder to help with the workload in that department.
Any questions about general fund?
And the biggest is the capital project fund.
So, um, some of the rollover items are
some improvement in Nolan Park Bike Park.
We're currently doing the Quarry Ride parking lot and,
um, some money for Pony Express Regional Park,
Silver Lake Community Park, and then, um, a street or
a transportation project, Silver Lake and Woodhaven Right Turn Lane Project, that was
previously, um, approved. And in terms of new funding,
um, there is grant money that we'll be receiving for the new asphalt
trail from Walden Park to Cedar Corners, and,
um, also some sidewalk
widening on Golden Eagle near Brookhaven Elementary School.
And then as part of our discussion this work
session, these are some of the few items that are being requested.
These items are for rollovers as well.
Eagle Monument, about $6,000,
$7,000. Digital info display, about $268,000.
And then wildlife corridor fencing, which is the grant money that
we received through the Division of Wildlife Resources, about $200,000.
And some transportation items are, as mentioned,
some widening in the Pony Express area. This is for construction that
is planned for February 2027. The, um,
budget requested is $1.8 million. Um, it will be 2
to— for 2 to 5 lanes and removing that median.
Um, so this one is from Eagle Mountain Boulevard to Shadow Drive.
And then for Phase 2, um, they're requesting a,
a design money or funding for $250,000
that will be, uh, hopefully be done this fall 2026,
looking into between 3 to 5 lanes,
putting some traffic signals at Parkway Fields and
Paul Canyon Boulevard, and also realigning Paul Canyon Boulevard and
Pony Express intersection. And then some improvement
in Silver Lake neighborhood about
those roundabouts in Woodhaven and Silver Lake and Golden
Eagle and Silver Lake areas. It's $250,000.
It's— the plan is for this fall of 2026,
replacing them with traffic signals and also realignment of roads and
crosswalks. Any questions about capital
projects fund? So if we— I
mean, I know we have the speed study that's happening right now. We're going to
get the results here pretty soon. There's going to be Money that we're gonna need
to help execute that? We're gonna just have to reallocate
from the currently planned capital projects?
Is that what we'll have to do in order to fund that? I think part
of the plan is to, as part of our retreat, that will cover some of
discussion about capital projects. So right now, once we roll over some of this
money, I think there is a $200,000 that is already budgeted, which is
not enough. And then when we do the retreat
and we can discuss all these capital projects, and then we can figure out
the priorities and then reevaluate, and then we can reallocate some of this funding.
Any other questions for capital projects? I have one question. The trailer
rental that you referenced. Yes.
I'm just curious why we're not buying a trailer. I guess that's the thing
that's been banging around in my head is why are we renting one instead
of just buying one? That's a good question.
I don't know if Brad or Mack can help me with this one.
I don't have a solid answer for you today. I just, I mean,
it's how we've done it. It's been a rental trailer since It's existed
there. I think it's probably been there 2, 3 years.
And so— We just keep renting it. And I'm just thinking— It's something we can
definitely look into. If we're renting it year after year, why aren't we just buying
it if we need it? Here comes the answer. Yeah,
this has been a temporary solution as we try to get the funding mechanism in
place for the admin building. So this will be a
part of this project that we're underway Okay. Our hopes was to do
that building first, but with funding and whatnot, I didn't— I mean, what's that look—
what's that timetable looking like? 3 years?
Yeah, we're tracking like a 3-year window on that. So, Mac, maybe you should come
back up. So, I mean, if— so if, if, if we
can see, if it's foreseeable that we're going to be using this trailer for the
next 3 years, why aren't we buying it? Or what does it cost us a
year? my understanding, these things are not cheap, and the, the rate that
we're paying, we'd have to have it for probably another 7 years to
break even. But that'd be a question that we could ask Jeff, as he
was the original facilitator of this.
Do we— what's the— you're asking what the lease rate is, right? Do we know
what our lease payment is on that? It's, uh, $18,000 a year.
$18,000? $18,000. Oh, $18,000. But it
is fully furnished.
Yeah, for me, that's, that's just one— that's the, the thing that stuck out to
me is I thought, man, why aren't we just purchasing this? And I know that
one of the solutions too that we've talked a lot about is the North Service
Area, and, and maybe we could put a trailer up there in the meantime,
but hopefully that's less than 7 years. Potentially a
City Hall, less than 5.
Originally, it was hoped, and this might have led to this, originally it was hoped
that we would do the admin building first. But because of the cost of the
overall sewer treatment plant, we want to make sure that we have the wiggle room
and have the administration building at the end to make sure that we have everything
that we need to take care of the citizens' needs with sewer processing and
then use the rest for the administration building.
It's all timing.
What does Kimberly say? It's all the Yeah,
you know, I guess I don't have any major concerns about it. I just,
I just wondered if we'd been down that path with that one item.
We can look into it.
Any other questions on the presentation before we go to public comment?
I just need to finish a couple more, sir. Mayor, you're right, I'm doing
5 by 5. I can finish them up and then we'll do the questions later,
if that's okay. Thank you, Mayor. So the next one will be special revenue
fund. Mostly these are related to the IFA
study, the impact fee analysis for water, wastewater,
stormwater, transportation, parks and trails.
The new items being requested is the software, as I mentioned,
that community development looking for plan reviews,
and also some contractual agreement for the White Hills well
water line project. For Enterprise
Fund, we're rolling over some of the water
and wastewater projects: well number 9, well number 7,
the 4 million gallon tank in City Center,
well number 8. When it comes to tied
to the wastewater treatment plant project, the Ox Ditch upgrade,
then we have Type 1 tertiary Treatment, and of course our 6
MGD wastewater treatment plan. In terms of new
items being requested, there are some equipment
requested by these departments for water and stormwater,
which included in the budget amendment. And then also there are some
additional funding needed for Well Number 5 upgrade. This includes
updating the electrical control panel, the switchgear,
and some PLC items for that, um, well project.
Any questions for the rest of the items?
I, I just have a question for Ben. Ben, you gave us an update on
well number 9 that they're at 1,000 feet plus or minus.
That surprised me, meaning they're moving along pretty well with that.
Is that going to come online for some of these others that we've had trouble
with. I see Brad raising his hand and Max coming
up to speak to it, but we have a
very good, experienced well driller, and so we're very pleased
with their progress. Yeah, so they're at roughly 1,300
feet. Yeah, they're cruising.
They're anticipating this being wrapped up by the end of tomorrow as far as the
drilling, and then they'll start the process of What
does that mean for timing, Mac? I mean, what do you think? I mean,
timing, we're probably another 45 days from wrapping
that up. We'll have to do a test pump. Once we get that reviewed,
then we'll go into design. So we're probably another year
before that's operational. We're just
trying to improve the average from wells 7 and 8 and having
9 all come together too. a consistent average. But Ben, that's why I
asked, because having had the experience with 7 and 8 and what a miserable
experience that's been, frankly, and at 7 in particular,
right? And our residents don't know all that story,
but seeing that number 9 is going the way it is, I'm thinking maybe
that will develop quicker on a shorter timeline than what we've been dealing with 7
and 8. That's hopeful. I also
think that there's some other components just for record too. So Well 9,
obviously we'll have to test pump it to see what it is so that we
can design the well house and all the motors and everything. But there's also
the conveyance, the water lines, the water system that we need to connect into it
as well. And so those are future projects that are on the capital project
plan that we'll have to facilitate, and they'll have to be built in conjunction with
that. Coming online. So yeah, within the next couple years.
So yes, just for context. Yeah,
that, that well was done in less than a year, and the other
one's been 5 years and still not done. It's pretty impressive.
So any other comments on that?
All right, seeing none,
we will open the public hearing at 7:51 and
Look to Lacey. I know there's a few.
Brianne Salazar.
Okay, so my question was, um,
At least in terms of the vehicles, um,
why are vehicles not,
um, kept at the facility?
Um, why are vehicles allowed, specifically like
police vehicles, um, uh, park vehicles,
um, not kept here,
um, at the main Like City Hall.
Why are they allowed to be taken back and forth?
If you go to other states— I'm from back east— police
vehicles stay at the stations.
Police officers arrive to work, get their vehicle,
and then take it out for service,
go back to the office, get their, their car, and then
go home. That extra additional mileage,
and if the officer is not required to live in that
county, they're adding on additional mileage
that's not needed, damage to the vehicle that's not
needed, you know, all that additional extra
wear and tear on the vehicle that is completely not needed unless the
officer is required to live in Utah County or at
least within Eagle Mountain, which I don't think that they are.
So that is a lot of extra money that we
are having to spend on vehicles that
don't really need to be taken, one, out of
the jurisdiction or out of the
area. So that's something to look into. And then
the other thing is the transportation bid.
Um, is this the best bid
that was reviewed and received?
Um, $250,000 just for a
design, um, seems really high just
for showing what we're going to do for a
3 to 5 lane. I mean, call me
crazy, but it's a straight line. Um,
and then for the additional things for the parks, um,
are all of those things absolutely necessary to do right
now during this fiscal year? Um, I think it was— 30 seconds remaining.
Talked about previously to add some ADA things,
but any of the additional things, are they absolutely
necessary to do now? If not,
Wait. Thank you.
Joy Rasmussen.
So I'm going to ask that you not pass this budget
because when you were showing the slides up there with where things are going
for what projects, there was no dollar amounts listed. So we couldn't, like, add it
up and see if there's something else being funded that's not being shown to us,
like the admin building. I'm wondering what this admin building is. Is that by chance
the new city hall that you already bought land for and hired an architect to
do a study on that? Because I
just feel like there's not enough details here for the citizens,
and I think you could look at your budget and cut some things out so
you don't have to do the property tax increase. So I'm asking that you don't
pass it. Also,
the requirement for the pamphlet for the referendum
requires a fiscal and legal impact statement that should identify all funding sources
for the estimated cost. This is off topic.
She needs to stay on topic to the public hearing.
Okay, yeah, I would ask that you not pass the budget because there's not enough
details. Citizens have lots of concerns, they're paying a lot more attention, and there weren't
enough details up there. We can't sit here and do the math and make sure
that what you're saying you need is going to just those things and not something
else that hasn't been revealed. Thank you.
Missy Perry.
Hello again. So I was kind of pondering some
things while he was giving the presentation regarding the
budget and the different things that are like being added.
And to be honest, a few of them kind of raised my eyebrows a little
bit. And I can't help but think that this
is similar to like a shopping list of items. Right? You guys are going through
like, okay, we have parks, we have vehicles, we have
all of these different things that need additional funding or that we can like
put into like, um,
projects and whatnot. However, when times are tough
and things like are a bit tumultuous, which I feel like we're kind
of going into a big change with the
transition from Alpine School District to the Westlake School
District and everything that's gonna be happening in 2027. Those are
also things that are gonna be coming forth. And I feel like when
that happens, you need to start cutting things from
your wishlist, from your grocery list of, okay,
what do we need to keep? Obviously meat and vegetables are necessary.
Maybe we can skip on the dessert this year. Maybe that's something that
we can hold off on a year or two. Maybe we don't
change roundabouts into more lights. Maybe there's
a better way to use the roundabout. Maybe if we actually paint them and
properly sign them, maybe expand them, they could be utilized
correctly. And actually, they're better. Roundabouts are better on
traffic and congestion if they're used properly.
And you don't have to put up a light. You save $250,000.
And you don't have to run electric to a currently
existing roundabout. Maybe just widen it a bit, add proper
lines so people can see the lines and know how to navigate through
them correctly. But that is a big— that's another item that could
save us some money to help cut the cost from having to
put taxes on citizens for their property.
That money could then go— instead of property taxes increasing, we could
use These funds are things that we push off for
a different day or a different year that aren't necessary, that aren't—
we have to have these right now. It's the things that are needed.
Absolutely, we need public safety,
we need less congestion on the roads,
but there are some things that I think if we think about
it— 10 seconds remaining. You can come up with a better idea than just ripping
it out and putting in a light or just adding things
to parks. Maybe we just wait on that until
things are a bit more stable. Thank you.
I'd like to thank the residents for, for the, the questions and concerns that you've
brought up. We do want to make sure that we're addressing those. And so if
I've asked the mayor if I could take just a minute to maybe answer a
few of those questions, and maybe I'll go backwards Just hang
on, Ben. I just want to make sure that everyone's done. I don't know if
you meant to wait till the end, so I didn't know if you had a
specific comment. Are you— we're good? I have nothing else. Okay. Is there anyone else
that came to speak on this item that did not get an opportunity?
Okay, seeing none, I'll close the public hearing at 8 o'clock.
And, uh, go ahead. Thank you, Mayor. Um, so first of all,
I just want to address some of the things that, that were brought up.
As far as traffic safety improvements and things like that,
we do have a responsibility to ensure that we provide the
best possible safety to our residents and that
we do so using engineering standards and
that we follow those standards through
studies. And part of that is ensuring that we don't have intersections that fail.
And so when we have an intersection like right out here
here, um, where it's not a roundabout, it's a, a light at, at Trailhead and
Pony Express where it is failing and there is a safety hazard,
um, that's where those type of improvements go forward. And so,
um, those type of studies are needed in order for us to move forward,
and we also need those type of studies so we can have cost estimates to
be able to, um, plan for in our budgeting process. Um,
as far as, um, the budget amendment, this isn't the budget,
this is an amendment to the budget. And as Terrence has reviewed,
most of the things that were in this— and I, I believe
it was close to 90% or more than 90%— are items that are
carryover projects that are currently funded with current contractors
and everything on board. And so what we're doing is we're taking the funding
that was approved last year— because the project has spanned,
uh, fiscal years— it is moving that money so that it can
be spent this year, and we can fulfill those contractual obligations.
Otherwise, we would just leave those projects undone throughout our community.
We have to complete those projects, and we cannot spend money
unless it's been approved by our elected leaders.
There was a question with regard to the administration building. This is not
the new City Hall. Our new sewer treatment plant has a planned administration
building for the sewer department personnel
that would be operating that facility. facility or doing the collection system for
our entire city. And part of that sewer treatment plant
envisions an office building. We just want to make sure that we can
afford the processing portion of it before putting in the actual building portion,
because if there's something that needs to be cut, it would be the building,
not the processing. That's the most essential component.
But it is not a new city hall. You also— And I
think that's a good point. You know, I mean, what can we cut? What can
we tighten? We're literally— didn't we just hear that we're in a trailer?
Exactly. We are currently— And paying rent on a trailer. And paying rent. I mean,
it's literally exactly what we've been doing. And as
we move forward, if we can afford an
admin building, it would replace that trailer. And like Brett said,
we hate renting. Owning is way cheaper,
and that's part of that construction of a new sewer treatment plant. We've got
a bunch of employees. That plant doesn't run itself, correct? Uh, and we're currently
in a trailer. That— and by the way, that's been 16 years of
no— of cutting, correct?
Um, the last thing I wanted to address was, um, the take-home vehicle question
and the police vehicles and on-call vehicles and whatnot. Now, every city employee has
a vehicle that they take home. It is those employees who are on
call or would have responsibilities to come out during an emergency or during
a fire, during like as far as building inspection,
a water break. And we have those at all hours of
the day and night. And when we have an emergency need, our person—
Every hour of the day. Yeah, exactly. Every time there's an emergency,
we have to have personnel that can respond with the tools that they need to
be able to immediately provide benefit to the residents
incidents and not drive all the way back down to the Public Works building,
which is on the south end of our city. If that problem—
let's say they live in the ranches or they even live in Saratoga, they'd have
to drive all the way to past City Center
near the data centers where our Public Works facility is and drive all the
way back in order to respond. And homes could be damaged,
water could be lost, all sorts of problems could take place if
our personnel didn't have the on-call vehicles with the tools they need to do the
job effectively for the safety of our residents. Specifically, it was talked about
with public safety and police officers. Of course, the Sheriff's Department
is separate and they have their own policies when it comes to that. But having
been a city manager in both Utah County, outside of Utah County,
and in the entire nation, I can tell you that on-call
vehicles or police officers across the nation, typically the standard
is that they do take their vehicles home, and that is especially held
true in the state of Utah. I'm from New York. I lived— I've worked in
Iowa. I've worked in other places. The reason that
police officers, especially in the state of Utah, take their vehicles home
is because the prevailing feeling is that police vehicles on
the road create a sense of safety and stability, even if they're
in the commute mode. And having those vehicles out
out and about instills safety so that people drive better, they're more cognizant of what's
going on, and there's more security. And if an officer actually did need to respond
and they were off duty, they would have the tools and equipment that they need
to be able to respond as well. This is so much so in
the United States that the difference between regular
take-home vehicles and police department take-home vehicles is that the
IRS requires that if a take-home vehicle goes home,
let's say, with somebody who's on call, that commute time
is actually a taxable benefit to
that employee. And that taxable benefit goes on their paycheck and whatnot,
and they're responsible for that— those miles and the fuel
that they would use in their commute time. But police vehicles
are exempt from that by IRS standards, and that is because of
the overall greater good of having police vehicles on the street. And so police officers,
sheriff's department deputies, they are not taxed for their commute because
they could be called upon to respond at any time for any emergency anywhere in
the state. And they're all licensed by post throughout the entire state.
And so it's not just a jurisdictional thing. They could respond anywhere. So I just
wanted to answer some of those questions. Hopefully I've hit them all. There's a couple
more I can touch on, but also just On that vehicle one, why are
they not here? Because they're parked at our Public Works. We have limited stalls.
We barely have enough spaces. But we do have several that are parked here.
And we do have some that are here. And then also on the sheriff ones,
even though it's a need, newsflash,
we pay $9.8 million no matter where they park because we're on
contract. So it doesn't save us or cost us. It's absolutely a set
price. And I don't care where you drive that car because it doesn't cost me
any money. But these were all good questions, and we're glad that you asked them
so we could answer them for the entire public. Yeah, yeah, so that's— Mayor?
Yeah. I think there was one more, and I think it stems from what you
use the money for. There was kind of this parallel idea
of like maybe a family budget and going grocery shopping and getting
the extras or the fluff. And I think a lot of people see the parks
as The difference between a family budget
and the city budget is there are certain funds
that can only be used for certain things. And when
there's parks funds that come from parks impact fees,
we can't just shift those over and use them for water
or sewer or for an additional employee or anything like that.
They have to very specifically be used according to state
law for the things that they were collected for. for.
So while, um, I had the same question before
I ran for office, I was like, why are we spending money on Corey Ride
Park? Um, and before it was built. And I,
I think that it's helpful to understand the legal
limitations of certain dollars within a municipal
budget. I, I think that is a really good point. And I maybe just to
add on to that as well, um, we do have certain assets
in our community, and we want to make, make sure that we take care of
and maintain those. It's our responsibility. Those are your assets, and we want to make
sure we preserve them. And, um, to not take care of some of those
assets would be equivalent to you not changing the oil in your car.
Um, it might get you by, and you might not be able to— you might
be able to live for a period of time, but eventually you're going to have
to replace that engine. And so we want to make sure that we maintain
our assets to the very best of our ability for our residents. And yet
our level of service is really strained because we're spread very, very thin. And that's
why the council's looking to bring more staff on to be able to help with
enhancing our parks and open spaces. Can you also address how
it costs $250,000 to engineer something? That's the
last thing that I was waiting to get on right here. Yeah, and do you—
and what's the process of determining you're going to choose that particular
engineer? So we do have a procurement process, first of all, and this is something
that I did for a living. Not the procurement, but the actual construction.
And when we say design a road, you know, for $200,000,
first of all, the $250,000, we had talked about this earlier today
and we think it's going to be 70% of that. But this is a budget
amount. This is what we're putting in the budget so that we can make sure
that we can get the job done. Doesn't mean that's what it's going to cost.
Doesn't mean that's the bid amount. That's how much we have in our budget to
make sure that we get the job done. We think that that design's
probably closer to $200,000. But what that covers is
engineering for road base and inspections
and the water line and the sewer line. It's not just the surface that
you see. It's everything underneath it and designing everything
from the roads, the curves. I'm sure you want to weigh in, so I'm just
going to let you go ahead. Sure. And so there's other things too. There's also
signal I mean, you know, conduits, controls, being that they're— it's more complicated
than that, especially when you widen a road. You also have to get, you know,
on-site survey as well as look at the elevations, because roads aren't actually flat,
they're actually curved. If they were flat, we would have water standing on there and
you wouldn't be able to drive on it. So we have to look at what's
the curvature of the existing road, make sure we match it so it drains properly,
we don't have standing water out there. So then that drain is going to go
into the storm drain pipe that's actually underground. Yeah, where does
that water go once we design that? It can't have a belly in it or
it's no longer going to— it has to go downhill and then it's got to
be pumped up and it's got to go downhill, right? That's all design. The size
of the pump, how much water— if it's 7 lanes wide as
opposed to 2 lanes wide, how much surface is that in a 100-year
storm? Can that pipe hold it? That's a lot of math. How many hours is
that? It's a lot.
It's a lot of hours. So a lot of engineers, there's site surveys, verification.
I would just like to add to the point of this is that not only
do we comply with state procurement laws, we comply
with our own city procurement laws and responsibilities, our codes,
to make sure that we advertise properly, that we
receive bids from all competent contractors,
that we go through evaluation process, a scoring process. It's very regimented.
We have a purchasing person. We're going to be bringing on another
because we have so many projects, but it just doesn't include that one purchasing person.
Depending upon the project, if it's streets or if it's parks or water or whatever,
we have a whole group that score those things out. And it's
not necessarily always the lowest bid, I will admit that. It is the greatest
value to the city, and we have to look at that based on their qualifications,
what work they've performed in the past. You know, if someone right out of college
versus somebody who's done a sewer treatment project
of 6 million gallons per day before, and that they have proven
competence to be able to do that. We want to make sure that we have
the right people on the job and that we're using the taxpayers' resources to the
very best of our ability. We consider those dollars to be exceptionally
important and, and, and, and treat those with the greatest of
respect. And typically that does land on the lowest bid a lot of times.
A lot of times they are. A lot of times, sometimes they're qualification-based
as well. Yep. So, all right, I think we've answered most of those questions.
And again, we're happy to speak to anyone. You know,
one thing we're trying to do is make sure that the information is out there
because the last thing we want is to leave that unanswered. So if we didn't
answer something, by all means, we've all posted our phone numbers and we
love talking to residents to help you understand why we're where we're at. There's one
more question that didn't get answered. So it was brought up that the presentation that
Terrence did did not itemize the expenses,
but if you, if you go to the public agenda,
it itemizes every single item. So if you go to eaglemountain.gov,
you click on public meetings, you go click on the public meetings
portal, and then you click on today's
meeting, which it'll scan right down to it. You click on today's meeting, you click
on the agenda item, And you'll see a budget worksheet that itemizes everything line
by line by line. And that's also in your packet, so you've already studied it,
so this was more of a highlight, correct? Right, and the presentation that Terrence did
was more of a, it was not intended to go line
by line by line by line on everything. He was sort of hitting some highlights
that gave us an opportunity to ask questions, but we've been given this line
by line by line by line in advance so we could read through it.
So we could give Terrence questions, but it's there for anybody
to see. It's there for the public to see. It was not hidden. And then
the other thing I will say, so when it comes to a city hall,
because this has been brought up a lot, it's a long process
to build a city hall. And you have to, you've got to
buy the land and you got to design and it takes, you can't just do
it all at the same time. So you just, Budget for it slowly, year by
year by year, by completing step after step after step. So are we
progressing down steps? Yes, because we need to. And if you
look at other cities our size, they have city halls, and we're living
in rented trailers. And and I would invite you to talk
to our staff and ask them. Do your own independent analysis. Ask the staff
if we have enough space. Don't just trust what we have researched.
Go ask them. I'm gonna say something on that real quick. Quick if you want,
because this just came up today.
Fly a drone, go take a picture of this building and look at the square
footage of this building. From where we're sitting, everything on this side of us is
the library. There's no staff in there. This is the council chamber we use
for planning commission. We use it every single day for trainings, for meetings.
We have the sheriff's department in this quarter of the building on
this side. We have over 200 employees, but I'll call it 180 employees
roughly, and that's over 200 now, that are
in that quarter of the building, which has about— and
plus 3/4 office, which is 4 more employees.
9 offices for 200 employees.
That's it. Well, you've got that in addition to the Public Works building.
Yeah, but I mean, here, and, and the
rent office space that we rent on our north end of town, all rented,
and you can own any of the vehicles Cars parked outside of there every
night. All rented, and there's not enough space over there. Here in this building,
we have 9 offices for all of our— that we could
put in one building, be more efficient, and save a ton of money.
When we have a meeting here, and this is— I think the residents don't understand
this about the City Hall. It's not because I want— when the City Hall gets
built, I'll never see it. I'm building this— it's like plant a tree for
somebody, for shade for somebody else. I'll never enjoy the shade of that building.
The problem is when we have a meeting here and Steve needs to come from
that building and Brad needs to come from this building, and we spend hours
of wasted time coming to a meeting where we could be in the same building
and have our— get our work done and go to work and get more accomplished.
We will save money building a city hall. I will advocate
for a city hall all day long that I will never sit in because it
is the right thing to do and we need it. Our city is way overgrown
for this building. It's not even close. So, you know, I mean, I'll have
that conversation all day long. A city hall is not a want,
it is a need, 100%. And I
will advocate for that every day, even if I never sit in it.
So that's the city hall. I kind of cut you off, Craig.
I want to make sure— No, it's all right. You took my thunder and ran
with it, and you did a great job with it. Because I think the number's
important. We got like 9 buildings or 9 offices.
Well, to your point, and you said it, like, we're doing something that I'm
not gonna— this is gonna be completed after our terms are done.
And this is a lot of decisions we're making, and that's why I made the
public comment earlier today. We're making decisions today to benefit the future.
This is not benefiting us specifically. And another thing
that I wrote down, I was just gonna let it go, but 99% of this—
I can't reach back there. Will you pat my back a little bit? Because you
already did earlier today. None of this is funded with tax dollars.
Most of this is money that we've gone out and got from MAG, from other
partners, from federal appropriations, from the state.
Today we were talking about $600 million,
$700 million, $800 million today. $500 million
on the one road and $300 million with the extension
of Mountain View, that I went up there and spent the whole day advocating
for, that I think we just moved up 15 years. Wait, I can't
reach again. I'm just kidding. It's not taxpayer
money. But I think this is, this is the point, Mayor. I mean, this is
something that I think our residents completely miss.
Property taxes last year raised $2.8 million in Eagle Mountain city,
period, across the board. That's all taxpayers.
$2.8 million. Every single thing we touch,
every project we touch is well in advance of $2.8 million.
A well costs us $7 or $8 million to put in.
So it's not coming from property taxes.
I, I just, I just think that we miss that, and I think it's important
that we underline that even with an increase of 60 67%
or 69%, that number still is
only going to go to somewhere around— $4.5 million.
$4.5 million, which is, which is a truckload
of money if it's in my bank account. In the city's
coffers, $4.5 million is a drop in the bucket and will fund perhaps
one small section of road improvement. I mean, I just think
that's really important that we put it in context.
We don't all deal with budgets like this. I never dealt with budgets like this.
I don't deal with budgets like this in my own personal finance. But I
think it's important that we understand it, and we need to get— we need
to get to a place where we can actually have a meaningful conversation and
quit harping on those things that are just myopic
and lost, in my opinion. They're just lost.
And I think it's because we haven't done a good job of giving context.
I think that's part of the problem, is we haven't done a
good job of giving context so that she— so that our citizens can understand
what we see and what we're dealing with on a daily, weekly basis.
And so that, that's where we need to do better. And I think it's probably
important to note too that with the council passage of its code last
week, it bound themselves by ordinance
to use those dollars in— Orderly.
For public safety, as they committed to verbally. Now they're bound by ordinance
to use those for public safety purposes, and that $4.5 million is
really only half of the cost of the police department's contract.
So money is still coming from other places to pay for But all of the
public's property tax dollars, 100%, whether they come from residential or
commercial or data centers or wherever, all property taxes go
to pay for nothing but public safety because we all benefit from it together.
All right, I'm going to pull out my inner Marcus and say we're getting off
track. Let's go. And say
we got to bring this back to the item at hand and ask if
there's any other questions. I think we've answered those questions and we're happy to have
conversations further. Even if we don't disagree, don't agree,
I still love the conversation. So no other
questions? Terrence, do you have anything to add?
If not, Brett, go to work. I'll make a motion. Mayor, I move that the
Eagle Mountain City Council approve Resolution 16A,
approving the first amendment to the fiscal year, the budget
fiscal year 2026-2027. 2027 annual budget as presented by
Terrence. Second. Okay, and just to be clear, that was
with the, uh, with the— okay, although I think it was presented
as he presented it. Yep. Yes. Okay, uh, we have a motion by Councilmember Wright
and a second by Councilmember Clark, and we'll start the vote with Councilmember Whiting.
Yes. Councilmember Clark. Yes. Councilmember Wright.
Yes. Okay, that motion passes.
All right.
Marcus, stay on topic.
We're going to have some training and
learn about the Open and Public Meetings Act. And, and maybe
as an opening to this too, uh, this is Open and Public Meetings Act for
the public's sake. Uh, once a year we're required to provide that training to
our elected leaders. And so, Mayor, I, I would highly encourage you to ask our
2 council members who are not here to watch this portion of the meeting
because this is really beneficial. But not only them, but our planning commissioners
and any other boards that's really— actually, uh, so I delivered
this to planning commission last week, and I talked to the board
between the meetings and told them they should listen to this. So, and I know
Charlotte's still here, um, so we can pass this information
on. I believe Jesse might be online. So,
um, she is online. So I think I think,
to your point, I agree, and I think we need to make sure that gets
out. Steve is— maybe we lost Steve, but whoever sits on those boards,
make sure that we get that out. There he is. I just couldn't see you.
Okay, so this is a combination Open Meetings Act training
and Municipal Ethics Act training. So we're
gonna start with a little video just to highlight the Importance
of understanding the rules. Okay,
please thumb— oh, there you go. I tell
you, I gotta plead ignorance on this thing because if anyone had said anything
to me at all when I first started here that that sort of thing was
frowned upon, you know,
because I've worked in a lot of offices and I tell you, people do
that all the time. So, uh,
It's important to understand the rules. Ignorance is not an excuse. It's a well-known
maxim in the law. As an attorney, I always
advise clients, you know, you need to inform yourself, because ultimately
you're responsible to abide by the Open Meetings Act in this case.
So the purpose of the Open Meetings Act is the intent of the legislature that
the state, its agencies, and its political subdivisions, including cities,
take their actions openly and conduct their deliberations openly. So that's
why we have open meetings. That's why we make these decisions in meetings like
this, is so that it can be done in the face of the public.
These laws are important so that
citizens can see how the process works. Okay. So just
as an opener, potential penalties for violations of the Open Meetings
Act are somebody could institute a suit to void a
final action on something that's done in violation of the Act, that there are criminal
punishments involved, and ultimately a violation by an
elected official could lead to expulsion from office.
Okay, so the default rule is
that a meeting is open to the public. Meetings can be closed
only for very specific reasons outlined in the statute.
I think you're very familiar with What the
reasons we usually close a meeting for are related to pending or reasonably imminent
litigation, land purchases or sales,
or discussing the competency of an
individual. So whether that's in relation to hiring
or firing, or if it's in relation to contracting, or whatever the case may
be. So it requires a 2/3 supermajority vote to close
a meeting. So in this case, it would typically require
require 4 votes. Okay. So the question then is,
what is a meeting? It is actually a term that is defined in the Open
Meetings Act. It is the convening of a public body with a quorum present.
So the convening is done by the person with authority to convene a meeting,
which in our case is either the mayor or 2 council members.
So with a quorum present, which is 3 individuals on
the council exclusive of the mayor, including a
workshop or an executive session, whether in person or by means of electronic communications,
for the purpose of discussing, receiving comments from the public about,
or acting upon a matter over which the public body has jurisdiction
or advisory power. So the simplified version of this is a—
you have a quorum, so 3 individuals, and you are discussing public business.
Yes, are you going to say something? Craig? Oh, it looked like you were
gonna say something, okay. So this, a meeting can include phone calls,
video conferencing, emails, text messages, et cetera. It doesn't have
to be a formal setting. So the rule of thumb
is if you are in a quorum, don't talk about city
business, which I know can be hard to do because what one thing do you
all have in common? So,
it's that you're all elected to represent the city. So as I
said, a quorum is 3 members of the city council exclusive of the mayor.
It's specific in the statute. The mayor does not count in determining
whether a quorum exists. Chances of social meetings are
not subject to the Open Public Meetings Act, but they cannot be used to circumvent
the requirements of the act. So if you wanna go bowling together, that's fine.
Just don't discuss city business. It's not a meeting and therefore
not subject to the act. Again,
typically we would only discuss items that are properly noticed.
There's, again, noticing requirements, there's emergency noticing
requirements, all sorts of things. But you can't take final action on anything
that isn't properly noticed. So if there's a discussion item and you—
there's something that comes up where it says City Manager items and we talk about
it, you couldn't take final action on that unless you specified what
item you were going to take final action and notice that that separately.
Okay. So this is an important one because this
is, I think, 2 years old now since the legislature added this. I think
it's an important rule, which is individuals
constituting a quorum of a public body such as the city council
may not act together outside a meeting in a concerted and deliberate way to
predetermine an action to be taken at the meeting on a relevant matter. And relevant
matter is a defined term. It's just anything within your jurisdiction.
So, what that means is that if one councilmember
talks to a second councilmember about a relevant matter, that's fine.
They can even predetermine their action if they want. I wouldn't advise it, but that
is not against the law. If they then talk to a third councilmember,
even if it's not all together at one time, then that,
and they predetermine the action, that would be considered a violation. And here's a
good example of it. I think most of you have seen this. But I
think it's hard to find Open and Public Meetings Act videos,
but this is a good one, and from a— you wouldn't expect it from casino.
Chairman, members of the commission,
Mr. Wollstein is pleased to be here today. And when the day finally came,
I was ready. I felt so confident that all I had to do was present
my case. And we have documents, one of which is a report by retired
FBI agents which completely absolves Mr. Rothstein from any wrongdoing.
I'd like this marked, Mr. Chairman. Pardon me, Counselor, before you continue. No, I want
to have this marked. This commission is prepared to act on a motion denying the
Rothstein application. Deny it! Do I hear a motion seconded?
Mr. Chairman. Mr. Chairman, I second the motion. Do I have a vote on
the motion? Mr. Chairman. Aye. Aye. Aye.
The ayes have it. This hearing is adjourned.
Okay, so I show that video because it I
think demonstrates the rationale behind the Open and Public Meetings
Act. Here, obviously, you see this really, you know, very full table
full of what appear to be case reporters. I'm not sure why they would need
half a dozen case reporters filled with mostly irrelevant
cases, but apparently they have that. They have a bunch of documents. They spent hours
preparing for this. And before they've had any discussion on the matter, they vote and
decide it. Obviously, this is not the purpose of the Open and Public Meetings Act.
What we want to do is have that deliberation, let them present
their case, deliberate about it openly, and then make a decision, not have it predetermined
like it was, as what happened in this case.
So now I'm going to go with some hypotheticals.
Hypothetical 1, and I've changed these from previous presentations.
So Councilmember A meets with Councilmember B to discuss
a preliminary plat application coming coming before the city council on the next agenda.
Councilmember A convinces Councilmember B that preliminary plat
does not meet the legal requirements. They decide to vote against it at the next
meeting. Is this a violation of the Open and Public Meetings Act?
It's okay to answer if you know the answer.
Not a violation. Why?
It's just 2 of them. Does not constitute a
quorum. But it still does create— But what you don't want to do is predetermine
an outcome. Yes. That's the key. That's where you're trying to trick
us. So I would say that this is not a violation, but does somewhat go
against the spirit. But it kind of borders on one that is potential.
Well, this is not a violation because there's not a quorum. Now, I would not
recommend that you predetermine actions. It's fine to
form opinions, of Of course. You look at the preliminary plat, you think it doesn't
meet the legal requirements, it's natural to form that opinion based upon review.
I would expect you to form an opinion. Certainly, maybe not set in stone,
but certainly form an opinion prior to the meeting, because that means you studied
the issue. What, you know, even predetermining in this sense is not
actually a violation, but maybe against the spirit of what you're being asked to do.
Okay. Hypothetical number 2. Councilmember A speaks to the mayor about a development
agreement on the next On next week's city council agenda, and they agree on several
specific changes that need, sorry, there's a typo, need to be made to the agreement.
The mayor contacts Councilmember B and discusses the matter.
Councilmember B agrees that the changes are important and indicates that
he will support them. Is this a violation of the Open and Public Meetings Act?
Trick question. It's not very tricky.
So it is not a violation.
Again, because the mayor does not count towards the quorum, that's the principle
being illustrated. Again, when you're going through agreements,
if you think something needs to be changed, obviously you're the
policymakers, you make those decisions, and it's okay to
form an opinion on that. Obviously you should be open to reconsideration or
amendment or modification of those, what changes you think need to be made, or be
willing to be convinced that they don't need to be made. and discuss that in
the meeting. But forming these opinions and even discussing it among 2
council members and then the mayor is not a violation of the Act.
So there you go. Hypothetical 3.
Council Member A speaks to Council Member B about a rezone application in front of
the City Council next week. He convinces Council Member B to recommend approval.
Council Member B speaks to Council Member C to get her support. Council Member
C dislikes the rezone application and declines to give support.
Is this a violation of the Open Public Meetings Act?
Yes, because they combined A, B, and C
and had a discussion by proxy.
That's correct. So the fact that Councilmember— Oh, sorry.
The fact that Councilmember C predetermined
something different than Councilmembers A and B does not matter. Okay.
So it's still a violation.
Okay, hypothetical 4, same facts except that the discussion occurs via text
messaging. Is this a violation?
Still yes. Still yes. Okay. Text messaging doesn't change
the legal landscape. It's still a violation. Okay,
hypothetical 5, during an open meeting, council votes to go into closed session.
During the closed session, the city council discusses potentially suing a contractor over a bridge
contract issue. Councilmember A asks how this will affect other agreements with the same
contractor. Is this a violation of the Open Public Meetings Act?
Got it. Well, they, they can go to a closed session because they're
talking about litigation, so that's acceptable. They can discuss
that, and I think they can discuss the ramifications of it, is my own
opinion of it, but I don't know on that second part of the question.
The problem comes for me when Member A asks how this will affect other agreements
with the same contractor, because those are not part of the closed session item.
So my favorite answer in the law is, of course, it depends, right?
So I think a narrow discussion of how potentially
suing a contractor, which again would
fall within the reasonably imminent litigation, because you're actively discussing, should we sue this person?
You know, whether, how that will affect the total landscape with that same
person, and the effects of actually instituting a lawsuit,
I think if you keep it in that narrow scope, you're fine. The issue
comes when you don't keep it in the narrow scope, and then you run into
problems. So, it's one where you have to be very vigilant in
making sure that your discussion is specific to the lawsuit,
and so your discussion of those other agreements is specific to the lawsuit's
impact on them. And that's why you sit in every closed session and keep us
on track if we start to wander slightly. I mean,
Marcus has us on a short leash. Anybody who sees me out
here knows I like to enforce rules, or at least I'm willing to.
Okay, hypothetical 6. Same facts as hypothetical 5.
Councilmember Beas About whether the city should terminate the contract,
and what contractor the city should procure as a replacement.
Is this a violation? Yes.
Yes, and again, this is what I talked about last one, right? We gotta keep
ourselves very narrowly tailored on that discussion of those other contracts,
and discussion of the lawsuit. And the second we start talking about, well, who should
we get to replace them, then you're all of a sudden, you've crossed the line.
So don't do that. Okay, hypothetical 7. During closed
session, the city council discusses the professional competence of Company 1, whose services the
city is considering using. Is this a violation of the Open and Public Meetings Act?
Yes. Why? Because it's an individual, not a company.
That's correct. So the— you're
allowed to discuss the professional competence
Competence of an individual. Individual is defined as a human being in this context.
Sometimes we use the word individual in the law to not just mean human beings,
but also legal entities. But in the context of the Open and Public Meetings Act,
it literally means a human being. So talking about a company, unless you're talking about—
unless company 1 is like an individual, say like
it's a lobbyist, and they're the company, it's just one individual, then maybe you
could talk about that individual's competence. But as
far as, you know, you're talking about like Meta, obviously no.
You're not talking about anyone's, any specific individual's
confidence. You're talking about the company. So that would be a violation. Okay. So thus
concludes the Open Meetings Act portion of the
training. Are there any questions?
No, but it's always fun to have you try and trick us, Marcus.
I do what I can. Try to
make it interesting, so try to make you think so it's not just rote memorization
but actually critical thinking. So, alrighty, let's go to Municipal
Officers and Employees Ethics Act. All right, from the
beginning. Okay.
So the purpose of this, of the
act, is to establish standards for conduct for municipal officers and employees and
to require these persons disclose actual or potential conflicts of interest between their
public duties and their personal interests. Okay.
So here's the first thing. It's unlawful to disclose improperly used private,
controlled, or protected information acquired by reason of your official
position in the course of your duties in
order to further substantially your personal economic interests or to secure special privileges
or exemption for you or for others. Okay. So this
is pretty straightforward. In the event that you come into contact,
and I don't think most of you would on any sort of regular basis,
but in the event you come into contact with private control or protected records
or other information that would fall under that, you can't use that for your
own gain. I think this falls in the common sense category. Whenever you
obtain something via your public service and you
try using it for personal gain. I think common sense tells you that might be
wrong. Okay.
It is unlawful to— and so anytime— so I just want to clarify something.
Anytime in the law we say unlawful, it means it's a crime.
So sometimes you say, you know, you can violate the law and it's just there's
implications where you could be liable in a civil suit. But anytime
you use the word in a statute or in an ordinance that says it's unlawful,
it means you're committing a crime and could be prosecuted.
Okay, it is unlawful to knowingly receive,
accept, take, seek, or solicit directly or indirectly for the
officer or employer or for another a gift of substantial value
or a substantial economic benefit tantamount to a gift that would tender improperly
influence a reasonable person in your position to depart from faithful
and impartial discharge of your duties, that you know or should know
that under the circumstances is primarily for the purposes of rewarding
you for official action taken.
So either of those things. However, there is a safe harbor provision that
says an occasional gift valued at under $50 is okay.
So if you're at a conference and you receive
a free meal from a sponsor and it's less than $50, that's presumptively
okay. Again, these are— That's
the safe harbor provision. So that's a presumption. It doesn't mean that
because something's $51, it's necessarily a violation. That's always a
case-by-case basis. The $50 is simply a safe harbor provision.
So when I was younger, not so much anymore, I used to like Law and
Order. When I became a lawyer, I started to dislike it, because I see all
the things that are wrong with it. But when I was younger, I liked
it. And there's one episode where one
individual murders his brother, and his mother, who is a rather
wealthy individual, a wealthy businesswoman,
then essentially bribes a judge to
let the surviving son, make a ruling in favor of the surviving
son to get compelling evidence of his guilt
suppressed, and thus the case dismissed. And so the
way that she undertakes to provide this bribe is to
arrange with the bank that her business banks with to provide a substantially
below market rate loan for the mortgage for the judge. So she's
not actually providing anything, and that is basically, if you
look at the definition of substantial economic benefit tantamount to a
gift, that is basically what is described, is what occurred
in that. Episode. So anything where you would
receive something of value, whether it's, you know, somebody is going to
sell you something at below market rate because you are on the city
council or an elected official, that would be problematic.
You know, again, the language
here is it has to be something that would tend
to improperly influence you. Or that would
tend to be a reward. So, you know, you get invited
by a developer to some sort of event that they're hosting,
not just for the city, but for many, including employees
and elected officials of the city, and they're offering you benefits at
that thing, then it's just a question of, is this less than $50?
If it is, I'm probably under safe harbor. If it's more
than that, then it's probably a bad idea to accept, because it could
be construed as a reward for official action taken.
Okay, so let's go to another video.
Hey, Tom, check it out. Norton Construction just sent this over.
Whoa, mama. I love Great Lakes wine. No,
no, no, no, no. You know as well as I
do that we are not allowed to accept gifts over $25 for
corruption reasons. We live in a fishbowl, and the public is always watching.
But you cannot enjoy this basket. I'm so sorry. And so to avoid
temptation, I'm going to lock it up. Okay.
So apparently the rule in Pawnee is $25, not $50,
as a safe harbor provision. But so again,
that's kind of illustrative of the, you know, if it's something You know,
when in doubt, you know, just don't accept the gift. I mean, maybe this is
a bit overkill here, but there was booze in that if you
watched the episode. So probably not a good idea to accept. Ooh,
hey. Okay. So, all right.
It's unlawful to use or attempt to use the officer's or employee's official position
to further your personal economic interests or secure special privileges
for you or others. Again, this kind of goes in the common
sense territory. Don't use your office to make money
for you or your family or your friends. So, cut.
There's a million ways to exploit your power, but have I ever given in to
that temptation? No, never. I'm not that kind of politician. Official Parks and
Rec business. Just need to grab a quick hot dog. Sorry about that,
little girl, you can have the next one. I have a moral code and I
never violate it. People look at me and they say, wow, Tom, You are so
pure. You're like a brown Superman with a beard that just stands for
justice and truth and the American way.
Yeah, don't do that. So obviously this is, you know, a humorous
representation of kind of what not to do, and it's obviously on a very
small scale. But yes, we don't use our office,
our position for personal gain. They call
it public service for a reason, so. Okay, so these violations can be prosecuted
criminally, and depending on the value of any benefit received, it could be up to
a second-degree felony. Anywhere from a Class B misdemeanor to a second-degree felony depending
on the value of the gift or other benefit received.
So just don't do it. When in doubt,
you have my number, so just call, we'll discuss.
And yes. Okay, so part of the Ethics Act,
In fact, I would say the majority of it is dedicated to disclosure requirements.
So it is an offense, which is another term that
means it's unlawful, for a city council member to receive or
agree to receive compensation for assisting any person or business entity in
any transaction involving the city,
unless you file a sworn statement with the mayor.
And follow the requirements. You give a description of what's going on,
and you disclose it in an open City Council meeting.
So those are the required disclosures.
Under state law, that's all you're required to do. As we'll discuss later, under city
law, you would also be required to recuse yourself from any action related
to that. So,
okay, more disclosures. A City Council member who is an officer, director, agent,
or employee, or the owner of substantial interest in any business entity
which is subject to the regulation of the city shall
disclose the position held and the nature and value of the interest upon first
becoming appointed or elected to the city council,
typically elected, and anytime thereafter
if any of the information changes.
So disclosure is in the form of a sworn statement to the mayor and the
city recorder. And the mayor provides a copy or outlines the substance
of the disclosure to the remainder of the city council. Okay, an interest of $5,000
or less need not be disclosed, and that's out of the statute.
A city council member who is an officer, director, agent, employee, or owner of substantial
interest in a business entity which does or anticipates doing business with the city shall
publicly disclose to the members of the city council immediately prior to any discussion of
any— by such body concerning matters related to that entity.
And the nature of the interest. So again, so there's the disclosure you give
to the mayor in writing, and then hey, now it's got business in city
council on the agenda. You have to disclose it immediately before the item is called
on the agenda. And you know, again, under city code, you would also recuse yourself.
So violation of the disclosure requirements could lead
to expulsion under the statute if they were proven would lead to expulsion.
And it also makes any action in violation of the disclosure requirements
voidable, which is important distinction
under the law. Void and voidable mean 2 different things. Void means it never took
effect. Voidable means if you do certain things after the fact,
you can void the action. So you can void it.
It's not necessarily per se voided.
Okay. All right. City code.
Each public official who is a member of the city council shall disclose disclose every
conflict prior to consideration of any action.
And again, also for purposes of
this chapter, the official has a conflict of interest if they know or have reason
to know that a parent, spouse, sibling, or member of the same
household, agent, principal, client, employer, or employee also
would violate any of these things or would meet any of these requirements.
So if you're required to disclose, Under the state
act, you have to both disclose and then recuse. If you
have an ownership interest in a business having matters under proper consideration for the city
council, same. All these things would involve disclosure
and then for an agenda item recusal.
Have an ownership interest in property within Eagle Mountain City for which zoning,
conditional use, or development approvals are
under consideration. This would not
apply to a principal residence.
So if you own a house, you live in it, that would not apply.
But otherwise, yes.
Represents as an agent, professional services contractor, or other advisor
individual with matters under consideration before the City Council.
Again, if in your day job you're doing something to that effect,
for example, say you worked for LRB, there are
municipal financial advisors. When we're
doing municipal financial stuff, then you would have to recuse from that.
Okay, so has an ownership interest in business or property
that has been issued a business license by Eagle Mountain,
uses or develops property located within the city limits
other than your personal residence, And which
offers the same goods, products, or services, or would use or develop property
in a similar way as a business or property which has matter. So again,
this is related to, you have, you know,
you own property and you're a competitor to the person that's
being, that's getting rezoned.
So you would have a conflict there because they're
asking for a rezone and you're their competitor.
Again, this relates to zoning, conditional use, or development approvals.
If you own property that's gonna be affected indirectly or directly,
other than, again, other than a primary residence, then you would have to disclose and
recuse. If you have agreement with party seeking approval
that would finally financially benefit you, then same
thing. So hypothetical 1. Okay, City Councilmember A attends a conference to receive
training on his duties. Company 1 invites City Councilmember A to dinner and pays.
Company 1 has business before the City Council. The cost of the dinner is
$40. Is this a violation of the Ethics Act?
No, because it's under $50. That's correct.
Safe harbor provision, you know,
again, the standard is if it would
you know, reasonable person would, you know,
would be, I guess, influenced to not
impartially discharge their duties. However, if it's under $50, there's the
presumption that it's fine. Okay.
Dinner costs $75. Otherwise, it's the same hypothetical.
Is this a violation? I would say probably not.
It's outside the safe harbor provision. Would a $75 meal cause you
to change your vote? So I would assume not. But again,
at $51, is that a per se violation? No,
it's probably not a violation. At a $10,000 meal,
they take you to some White House fundraiser dinner, it's probably
a violation. Where you draw the line in between those 2 numbers is unclear.
So my advice is always just keep it under $50. You don't have a problem.
At $75, is it not a per se violation? But it could be.
So that's why I say it's probably not. You know, in some
contexts maybe. But again,
my advice would be don't do it. So,
okay. Hypothetical 3, city council member has a 25%
ownership interest in Company 2. Company 2 does business before the city council.
Does City Council Member B have any obligations under state or city ethics laws?
If so, what are those obligations?
Yes, you have to disclose your ownership interest, right? And,
uh, let's see, and then if that business
comes before the council, then you need to recuse yourself and walk
away and allow the council to deal with that outside of
your presence. Yes, so you would have the written disclosure obligation
to send something to the mayor, also would
have a disclosure obligation in the meeting to disclose it immediately before consideration and
recuse yourself. Okay. All right. So last part
is standards for civil discourse. So this is in the city code.
I think it relates to ethics in that obviously
the way that we relate and talk to each
other and the people who come and do business before the council, I think,
has an ethical implication. And so we do have these standards for civil discourse.
And state code basically says you should adopt
them, and that's what that reference to state code is in here.
But the purpose is, again, to meet our obligations
to each other and to the public by following these. So let's talk
about the standards. Conduct or language that is condescending,
uncivil, abrasive, abusive, hostile, or obstructive impedes the fundamental
goal of participating in civil discourse and public processes, and the
rational, peaceful, and efficient resolution of decisions, and is a violation of
this standard. Such conduct tends to delay and often to deny resolution
of issues in the public interest. So that's something to keep in
mind, is that when we are speaking to one another, sometimes discussions can
get heated, or when an applicant comes and
they have a proposal that sometimes discussions
can get heated. It's always good to keep in mind to keep
our conduct and our language within these bounds.
So, you know, they may say something
that you think is stupid or that doesn't make any sense.
We still treat them with respect and we explain why
we hold that position, not just say, hey, that's stupid.
So. Elected and appointed officials and city employees
should exhibit courtesy, candor, and cooperation in dealing with each other and
the public and in the administration of the city. Elected officials, members of
city boards and commissions, and employees shall not, without an adequate factual basis, attribute to
other persons improper motives, purpose, or conduct.
Each person affiliated with the city should avoid hostile, demeaning, or humiliating conduct and words
in written and oral communications. Neither written submissions nor oral statements or conduct should disparage
the integrity, intelligence, morals, ethics, or personal behavior of others. So,
uh, pretty, uh, self-explanatory. And that is
the end of the presentation. Are there any questions?
Very thorough. Thank you for the reminder, Marcus.
Perfect. Thank you. I was thinking to myself as you
go through that, some of the other things that I just highlight as a reminder
Of course, that was ethics and somewhat code of conduct, but in
our own code, you know, Section 2, just a reminder to read
that, and maybe the way we treat each other and talk to each other,
a reminder to do it civilly and treat
people with respect. So I sure appreciate that.
Is John still with us? There he is. You move
to a new seat every day, I swear. It's not your fault.
Good evening, Mayor, Council. Um, so I finally
got the quotes back for the reinforced— or the precast
fences. Um, to have a custom panel will range between
$20,000 to $30,000 to have it designed,
and then it would be no more than any regular panel
after that. So if they wanted to— if we want to come with a design
standard, we can create panels, a couple panels,
and then we can have whatever they have as fencing material to
come back to make it look blended all together.
Do you think that the arts facility fund, a quarter of
a percent could be used for that if it was designed in such a
way? Because I'm all about finding alternate
funding sources for it. I know that we had discussed something
like that. I think certainly, um,
streets, you know, a streets project, a percentage
needs to go towards arts, and you're beautifying the street while also Providing the safety
enhancements, and that's really what it all comes down to. You want to have a
safety enhancement, but the beautification aspects of it, if the cost is the same
and yet this element adds the beauty to
our community and continuity, sure, absolutely. It kind of reminds me of
the bridges on I-15 that either have like a wildlife
something or the Olympic something that's on them,
and they're restricted funds that can only be used for that. So it's like
Can we kill 2 birds with one stone? Not literally birds.
I think one of the goals— this is something I think Rich and I was
kind of talking about a long time ago— and could we, you know,
have our emblem on, on these walls and different things?
Uh, but really the goal was to save money
for the contractors to be able to have our own Forms, and all we'd
be buying is concrete at that point. So I think I heard you say,
uh, same money as far as the pour.
Yeah, after they design it, it would be just as expensive to buy that panel
versus one off the stock panel they already have. If you're gonna
buy it. Yeah, if you're gonna have somebody custom pour it.
But if we found a way to get a
concrete company to store those panels, I mean,
They're obviously making a profit margin by building those panels, so I
would hope that it's not— that if we had our own forms, that there's a
cost savings. What's the longevity of those
forms? What's the lifespan of them? Do you have any idea, John?
Anywhere from 800 to 1,000
pours. So you would only have a few of those custom panels mixed in
with a standard panel. Yeah, I mean,
that makes sense to me. I just wanted to know how often are we gonna
be looking at a mold charge? Right. In one of my previous
cities, there was an HOA,
a larger— yes, okay, it was Santa Clarita. In Santa Clarita, there was
a large HOA and large
subdivision, Summit Ridge community, where the HOA
went and the city The master builder actually went out,
got the forms, pre-built all of the
panels, and those were available as different
builders were building different areas so that they had continuity. And it just made it
one source and easier, and they were able to buy it wholesale. So it's
just an option, but— So,
So anything else on that? You said $30,000 and then— $20,000 to $30,000,
depending— it depends on how intricate the design gets.
The harder it gets, the more expensive it gets for the
poor. So an E might be a little cheaper than the full logo.
Right. Or just— or the eagle. The other thing is,
some of these places, some of the 3 different manufacturers I was able to get
a hold of, 2 of them— Pretty much do the
installs themselves. They do sell some to third-party fence
installers, but most of this they do the install themselves too. So we could be
in a position where we'd be locked into one installer.
Yeah, I mean, if, if we own the forms, we own the forms. We can
move and we could pour here if we wanted. But if we're asking somebody to
store stuff, we'd be— probably have some
kind of arrangement. But I So I don't know how to really handle this
report. It's something that I think we need to talk about. So I don't want
you to check it off as done. I think we need to maybe bring it
with Evan or something to a discussion because now it's— now we have
the info. What do we wanna do with it? We could put it on a
work meeting and let you guys have an open public meeting about it. So then
in that case, you wanna assign that out to, as far as who's gonna get
some info and bring us, you know, I mean, we got
the costs, just now what do we wanna do with it? Whether it's
design, do we do a couple logos, whatever. And I
could see what other cities are doing as well. Just do a simple blast to
the City Managers Association, that type of thing. I know Herriman has some
custom ones. So next time we have a light agenda,
Lacey, we'll add this on. So plan on like 2028.
I wanna make it clear that I don't wanna spend extra money on it,
but if there's restricted funds that can only be used for something like
the art piece or whatever, we talked about this when the art
quarter of a percentage was created, and I remember Mayor,
when he was on council, talked about manhole covers.
Like, we have to buy manhole covers anyway for a project.
We could put a design into them to— Do whatever,
and that's just part of it. So like,
I don't want us to try to find money from someplace else, but if we
have it in an art fund, to me that seems like a
good use for it. I'm fine with whatever direction you guys
say on that, even though I might slightly disagree
because of this. The goal is to help improve
some of the developers that haven't, you know, that don't find that cost-effective. This is
a way for us to get an elevated fence and
keep it cost-effective. So I think there's some value in that.
Although I do wanna use restricted funds, I don't know that that's a limiting
factor is all I'm saying. So yeah, let's bring that back with
those type of discussion points that we can hash out.
Next? At the next meeting, you're gonna discuss
The traffic calming, traffic study stuff. So that is coming back. And that
is all I have for you for all the updates on my side. The only
thing is, is there anything you guys want to add? I think just for Councilmember
Weitig's sake, I'm going to throw this out there. As that comes, tonight it was
brought up, the funding source. I know we set aside $250,000.
$200,000? It was $250,000. Anyway, I think we need to know if
there's, you know, 5 suggestions You know,
each one of those allocate a dollar amount so that we know kind of what
we're dealing with when we—I mean, we just—we're kind of throwing darts to
try to get this project moving, and we need to know what it's going to
cost. Yep. So we're meeting with them next week, and we'll make sure that we
have some estimates in there for all the recommended traffic calming solutions for each location.
I'm pretty sure you've been in the same meetings as me, so you've heard kind
of the higher priorities. Maybe start with those, and you know that we kind
of bring. So it will come with a. prioritization. That's what I'm hoping.
Our goal is to present like a matrix, so we have like all the locations,
what they recommended for the solution, and then also we thought
for some locations, you know, why the speed tables may or may not work for
that location and kind of talk through options so you guys can see it and
make those decisions.
So one thing we talked briefly about, ladder signs and
adding more ladder signs to the part of the city because we've had growth there.
Where, where are we at with that discussion? We were waiting
to hear back from that. Mayor, do I need to get up and leave?
Huh? Okay, we won't have a quorum,
but I— we're just seeing reports.
So, and let me reach back around. The chamber was supposed to be, uh,
giving us information on that. I haven't heard back from them, so let me reach
out to them. Sounds good. Okay, was there
anything else on that? Unless you have something else.
We can wait for a minute. We can do some
liaison reports. It's not a voting issue, so.
She's back. Okay, no sweat.
Anything to report? Laison? I'm meeting with the library board
for a quarterly meeting next week.
Chamber of Commerce is rocking and rolling. Met with them last month and they're
just, we're very blessed to have a very active,
robust chamber and they're doing a great job.
And I visited Shop Fest, it's epic. We're very blessed
to have it. And the— and we had a
meeting with the Eagle Mountain, the Youth Council, and there's tons of energy
with the Youth Council right now. We have tons of people coming to our
meetings, and it's just awesome to see that. And the youth are providing
lots of ideas. This last meeting was amazing. The youth are leading it, they're driving
it, they're providing a lot of input as to what's going on,
and it's, it's just, it's an awesome organization to be
a part of right now. Yeah, there's been some youth that have reached out to
me that want to join. But they wouldn't be voting members at this point because
of the new— Correct. They would not be voting members, but they can definitely come
to the meetings and give their input for sure and participate.
Yeah, and I wonder if they could be voted into the quorum if that
became, you know, I mean— We could. We just wanted to cut
it off at some point, but I mean, could we? We could for sure do
something like that. I mean, it's— Do— does that discourage people to join it
late? You know, I mean— Yeah, I mean, we ran a few weeks
before we cut it off, but— Let's just see what it does. But I
know there's a couple, and I think maybe you've been made aware of some of
them. I'm aware of one person that reached out,
and yeah, but I said come to the meeting and participate.
I mean, at this point, there's so many people
that are voting that one additional vote— I'm not that it's gonna persuade things one
way or the other, 'cause most everything they talk about seems unanimous anyway, or very
close to it. But what's powerful about people coming is they're giving
great ideas, and then there's just more bodies
to enact those ideas as well. I should have said this earlier, but I'm
even wearing my— I went to the suicide
walk and the youth council was there, and I've got my— I went and walked,
and that was cool. Some of the events I've been involved in the last couple
weeks have been pretty fun, and I, for some reason, I just believe in
this stuff, so I still wear the wristband I got. So that
was cool. And the Youth Council did— I see them everywhere. It's just fun.
Anything else?
Yeah, just quickly, Mayor. I mean,
LPC, I volunteered to be part of their water committee.
I'm not surprised. So just so that you're aware of that,
and Justin Lee confirmed that they're going to allow me to
help with that. And we do have LPC next Monday, just a
reminder for you and for Ben. Seniors— Wasn't Zach on there
as a voting member? Zach as well. Yeah, I'll reach out to Zach and remind
him. And then the seniors have got, you know, our chili cook-off
coming up in October, as I remember, and they're starting to
work towards the donations for the Thanksgiving basket. So if
you want to help with that, reach out to the seniors. They'll have a list
of Items that you can contribute. I, I see 5 o'clock, 5 PM
senior games on September 28th. That's on my calendar. But that
one got, that one got moved? Yeah, it got shifted around. That's the chili cook-off?
Yeah, they, they moved it to the end of October. I need to verify the
date. Okay, I see October— sorry, October 26th is what I see on that.
The September 28th I can remove off my calendar? Yep, take it off.
They changed it. Okay, they switched it on us. Got it.
And then just DRC. I hope each of you get
a chance to sit on the DRC for a year. It will really increase
your appreciation for what our staff does preliminarily before we ever see anything.
Mayor kind of gave me an assignment since I'm an evangelist
for UTA to meet with
Chandler, who's their government and community outreach person.
One of the issues that we found with UTA, the new on-demand system, is that
the system won't take you more than 6
miles unless you're going to a transit station. Well, for anybody who lives
in City Center and needs to get to a job at Ridley's
or Walmart, you can't get there.
And that's a problem for a city that spans from
Cedar Hills to Provo. Thank you. So we
are working with them to create some special
points that could get them up to Walmart,
and maybe Walmart's one of them, City Hall.
That is something that we're working on. I had the opportunity to go to the
kind of grand opening of On Demand, and that was really good because
I made sure everyone who had anything to do with planning at UTA
heard about the 6-mile limitation, and it was
good. I got to be there to represent our city while mayor was in New
York. I think it was when you were busy with that.
No, I think you were gone because I remember telling the other mayors.
Yeah, that one, that one I met with Chandler and
he— and by the way, he gave me like 4 on-demand passes that I would
offer to anybody that would try and use it or any of the council.
One of the— so 9 miles to Saratoga, we've talked about, to the kind
of employment center where Costco is. And I was asking that we bump that up
to get a little further distance. And as long as they're not busy, they've kind
of been pretty lenient on that 6 miles, but that's the rule. So we've gone
to Skyler Beltran and asked him to expand that. And that's
where I passed the baton. I didn't have the bandwidth for that one.
Well, I also think that Part of the issue is
that they have a limited number of vehicles that are in the system, and we
are out here on the outskirts of it.
If we can— 16 vehicles, and I think they had 1,000 rides the first
day. 1,000 rides the first 9 days, but that's still a
lot. Okay, yeah, they gave me some stats. I was like, yeah, it was good.
'Cause at the grand opening, they announced that it was 1,003 rides.
I think one thing that we as a city may need to consider is
finding funding or getting support from some
of the corporate partners within our boundaries to help fund
additional vehicles that are— will help staff
up more of the Eagle Mountain side of things
so that they can't say we don't have enough vehicles to do that.
This. So we'll go through the hoops of trying to get them to add
miles for us and add additional locations that we can go to.
But if that fails, which I'm not completely
convinced that it will pass, like UTA has
kind of let us down in the past, if that's the case, then I think
we as a council and a city need to look at whether or not
we seek funds from someone or some entity to help pay for that because
it's a huge benefit to our residents.
Council Member Wright just talked about our seniors,
Council Member Whiting talked about our youth. Everyone is using
this on demand and it's had a huge turnout. So I think it's
something for us just to think about. They said a lot of the kids,
like kids getting off of football practice because the buses have already left, have been
using it. So one of the other things that I think we could advocate,
and we could use the public to help us with this, is it's kind
of meant for those first and last miles to get you home from a bus
stop or something. But what would help is they will only
do 6 miles in those cases, like, you know, to your
home. But if we identify Costco and Walmart and the
high school, they'll do 10 miles if it's one of, you know,
a specific location. Right. So we're trying to identify and employment areas. Exactly.
I think the inherent problem with their 6-mile limitation,
Mayor, is that the whole thing— the reason why they justified
doing on-demand instead of the bus route that they came and announced to us
and said that they were bringing and then pulled back— is
that they want to find ridership numbers. Well, if there's a
third of our population is outside of that 6-mile
limit to get to Walmart or any other employment employment centers, that means
1/3 automatically isn't going to be factored
into ridership numbers because it's not useful to them. And I think that we have
to be a squeaky wheel with this. And you picked the right person
to send. I was just going to note that I got a call from
Bob Allen with MAG letting me know that
Saratoga Springs and UTA are applying for UDOT
innovation grant money in order to expand and extend that 6-mile
limit, and, and they wanted to know if Eagle Mountain wanted to join in
on that same application. I thought so. I know that I sent something in
to Mayor and Ben, and I think that you guys had talked about
Kimberly was going to have our grant writer start looking at that.
That deadline's coming up, and I don't want us to miss out on it.
When they had told me about it, there was only one other
city that had even submitted anything, and I know that Saratoga is doing it
too. We have a stronger case if we do something with them, I think.
Um, I, I had a meeting with Mark Christensen as well, and, um,
he, he encouraged us to put in an application. He thought that it
would be more beneficial. You can go up to $3 million per application,
and if we join in, then of course we're limited, but there's an
opportunity for both cities to put put in and potentially get $6 million for our
region. So he encouraged us actually to do it separately and try to meet that
timeline. I think we could have a whole other fleet with that amount of money.
Does it say— is it $6 million in a year or $3 million in a
year? I don't know the specifics. Those are just numbers he provided.
The grant's a 3-year funding, so that number
is probably a 3-year number total. But then, then we would have to
decide at that point whether we want— whether we have some other funding Or we
ask a corporation
to do a match. Or we
petition UTA to bring our own tax dollars back because we are already
paying for those dollars. That too. Of course,
you know, you've heard a lot of my reports with UFA and
at the Capitol, just different things I've got going. So unless you have specific questions,
I won't bore you with my 40 hours by Monday.
Mayor, can you, and maybe you talked about it and I just missed it,
did you talk at all about where we're at with UTA and the process
that we're trying to get figured out with UTA, not UTA,
UFA and UFSA and where
we're at with that? I met with them this morning and that we're
90% on the contract. She said she'll have it this week. Yeah,
that's what she indicated to me was that she's 90% finished with the draft
for me to review. Yep, that's what she said. And then we're working through
the tax code to try to figure out how to make sure that
we don't overtax in the transition or
undertax in the transition. And I think we got it figured out today, some solutions,
but it's more about also working with the state on
how to pull those funds in and to do it properly.
We've seen where mistakes have been made in other counties. So that's
really what the holdup. But right now, the answer to your question is December 31st,
2027. Right.
And we're also working with the league. We met with the league this week as
well to— because while
it would be an increase to our taxes, it would be a decrease to UFA
taxes. And the net effect is zero to our residents. And so Ultimately,
it should not trigger truth in taxation.
It should be a net zero to the residents.
And is there a possibility for legislative changes that would
allow for that? Logan ran into a very similar issue this year between the county
that was providing a service and a city, and they ran into that issue
and it became— it got onto the state's radar. We believe
that that would be very important for ARC. Thank you. because truth
in taxation should just be that, truth. And the truth is your
taxes wouldn't go up, it would just be transferring from one to another.
And the interesting thing is that the House rep, the rep that runs
a lot of the tax bills is in Logan. So it's
hopefully that it's on his radar. Well, I think it's
just like with the school districts. We have Alpine School District,
as a taxing entity right now. The Lake Mountain School District doesn't have to do
a truth in taxation to switch and bring that over. So I think I'm glad
you guys are pursuing that. That's what we're working on.
So yeah, lots of meetings. We've met with the league,
we've met with the state, we met with all those people this
week. It's been busy. It's Tuesday. Yes.
Anything else?
Yep. Go ahead. Mayor, I move
that, uh, we adjourn to a closed session for
the purpose of discussing,
uh, discussion of pending or reasonable imminent litigation, the character,
professional competence, or physical or mental health of an individual,
the purchase, lease, sell, or exchange of real property,
a proposed development agreement, project proposal, or financing
proposal related to the development of land owned by the estate
or political subdivision and/or the deployment of security personnel, devices, or systems
pursuant to Section 52-4-205,
Subsat 1 of the Utah Code Annotated. Second.
All right, we do have a motion by Councilmember Wright and a second by Councilmember
Whiting, and we will return to this meeting afterwards to adjourn, just so you're aware.
We'll start the vote with Councilmember Clark. Yes. Councilmember Wright.
Yes. Councilmember Whiting? Yes. Okay, at 9:17 we'll go to
closed session. Sometimes I think it's good to read those so that
the public understands the things that we can address. It's what we just learned.
You recording? All right, it is Maybe
my thing doesn't work. 10:21.
10:21, 10:22, and we're back in our regular session,
and I will entertain a motion. Motion to adjourn. Second.
Okay, I got Council Member Wright with the motion and Council Member Clark with
the second. All in favor? Aye.
Nobody opposed? That passed unanimous, and we are adjourned at 10:22.
I almost called you Council Member Wood, by the way.